the US has begun a massive bombing
campaign on Iranian revolutionary guard
Targets in Syria and Iraq basically
ladies and gentlemen the US has just
begun a very long protracted war in the
Middle East surprise surprise where have
we heard this one before I'm not
surprised it's happening but the
question is how will it escalate I
believe that the news we're seeing here
is basically it's a unilateral
declaration of war by Joe Biden we are
now attacking Iran the questions are why
is Iranian revolutionary why is Iranian
revolutionary guard operating in Syria
and Iraq and when did we declare war on
Syria and why are we there anyway I
think the uh unip Party The
Establishment realized you know the
problem isn't that we unilaterally
declare war and everyone complains about
it they're complaining about it because
we told them we did so now they're just
just go do it ignore it and don't talk
about it but now of course there are a
bunch of uh media outlets and a bunch of
politicians in various countries once
again saying World War II they've been
saying World War III for like a year now
so I don't know I guess are we in it but
basically got the UK saying gear up and
get ready several other countries have
been mentioned in the past week have
been contemplating or advocating for a
military draft and many news outlets are
saying this action by the United States
could be that escal
then of course we have the prospect of
Civil War right here on the border as a
new bill through Congress would
authorize the National Guard to use
lethal Force against illegal immigrants
in certain contexts now the easy context
of course is if they're facing something
lifethreatening but it also says and for
other reasons should be interesting
basically it looks like they are
advancing the position where we may
actually see combat On the Border or
some kind of force and the funny thing
about that is Ian is is the one who's
talked about his fear that it comes to
that point and I'm like well you know
that bills in Congress maybe it doesn't
make it maybe it does we'll see and uh
FBI is warning that China will be
attacking us domestic infrastructure so
perhaps there's just a whole lot of
World War II going on we'll talk about
that and then actually in some really
big and very good cultural news Joe
Rogan according to the Wall Street
Journal has secured a $250 million
multi-platform deal with Spotify the
reason this is really really good news
is the deal basically says that Rogan's
show will be everywhere YouTube Spotify
anywhere but Spotify is now going to buy
the ad rights to the show so that they
can basically sell ads against this show
what does that mean Spotify believes
Rogan and whatever controversies may
arise in the Press from his guests is
not going away and is profitable they
don't think they're going to lose money
on this deal and it's good for everybody
else because if Joe Rogan leads the way
Spotify is basically saying we're going
to put $250 million of our money up
front because we think we'll make more
money on this basically it's it's Paving
the way for everybody else who produces
content it is much more likely that
comedy and you know offensive kind of uh
uh content will not be taken down moving
forward because these platforms are
banking on it we'll talk about all that
before we do my friends head over to
cast brew.com
Appalachia nights ground is back in stop
stock but we only have 274 and I'm
sitting here like holy crap you guys
you're buying too much buy more uh the
reality is Cas Brew is it's our we
sponsor ourselves it's our compy
we're working on our coffee shop if you
want to support the show and you want
the best cup of coffee you've ever had
I'm going to tell you right now we are
struggling to keep Appalachia knights in
stock and I'm so excited this is the
case because I think we we hit one out
of the ballpark with this one uh rise
with Roberto Jr is the second favorite
and we we we got a balancing act with
that one but I like over the past week
we've been doing reorders we've had
reorders in in the past week and they're
selling out almost instantly and so uh
really excited and really grateful that
everybody is buying we're going to have
to order more and more but that is uh
success thanks to you you guys I
recommend you guys try it if you haven't
already cast brew.com also head over to
timcast.net server while y'all can hang
out share like-minded ideas or debate
and then we have the members only
uncensored show Monday through Thursday
as well as documentaries and other
content we're currently working on so if
you want to support our work go to
timcast.net
hour KLA Harris in the white house right
on so you basically uh
was it was it were you face palming
every time you had to write something
you're like wow I can't believe it yeah
it was really fun to research what's the
general premise of the book uh General
premise of the book is she's struggling
clearly in the first three years of her
vice presidency she clearly wasn't ready
to run herself that's why Biden's
running again and if Biden runs and wins
we're in a very real possibility of um
the 47th president becoming
Harris I don't think Joe Biden can win
but I also have no idea what's in store
for us this year yeah me neither uh if
if Joe Biden doesn't make it if he can't
make it to election day I think the
Democrat Party that's their worst fear
because that's when everybody with the
money as bad as Biden is losing their
mind they're like KLA worse that's kind
of funny all right man well uh it should
be fun thanks for hanging out we got
Hannah clay Balo as well hey I'm Hannah
CL BR I'm a writer for cnr.com I'm glad
that you're here because I feel like I
give Kamala a hard time all always she's
so easy to pick on but she's not great
uh so I'm glad you guys are joining us
tonight Shane's here what's up I'm back
it's good to be back sounds like Charlie
wrote a horror
novel and I'm scared U you're like
reading through it is this fiction yeah
it's it's terrifying stuff but it's it's
great to be back oh shout out to the
Discord I keep seeing stuff coming out
of the Discord it's amazing what you all
are doing out there and it's good to see
you Serge oh yeah how you seen the
Discord stuff man you uh Serge has been
inundating my phone today with stuff
that he gets from Discord and it is
laughing for the last hour yeah that's
great great no after show today but uh
yeah this scor rules I like uh being on
there every once in a while I am
surge.com let's uh get into it Tim
here's the big story today and of course
they did it on a Friday US drops 125
bombs and 85 targets linked to Iran's
revolutionary guard in devastating air
strikes on Iraq and Syria Biden warns
retaliation for drone attack that killed
three soldiers will continue after long
rrange bombers and drones hit Middle
East
uh unilateral declaration of war or is
it just we are in such a Perpetual state
of War they don't care they're just
going to keep ramping things up and
we're going to spiral out of control and
implode or uh or what they're used to
being a wasteland of our bomb shrapnel
it doesn't seem like it's it could
escalate into a regional War but they
telegraphed it to everyone that we'd be
bombing them so then everyone that might
have been responsible for the Drone
attack is gone and we're taking out what
could be the places where the drones
were um but we'll see know it's just
interesting to me because I was on the
phone today with a friend who's in uh
Special Forces for the Navy and he was
talking about whatever's going on his
life and then he was saying oh yeah I'm
supposed to deploy this fall and I was
like oh where do where do you think
you're going he's like oh we're getting
back in the Middle East but he says it
the whole thing he didn't say something
specific which makes me think that like
everyone is preparing for intense uh
escalation wasn't there uh something
about the Roman Empire bringing in
foreigners to fight in wars that is part
of the story I believe part of the story
does anybody know enough about the Roman
Empire come on men I thought this all
think about every single day yeah yeah
but seeing this you know it's perpetual
War the fact that Congress does not
approve of these things anymore we've
been at war in the Middle East for how
for for for decades or longer actually
and we're in Syria Iraq and Syria I mean
Iraq I know right and Syria when I mean
of course it happened with we never left
well with Obama we we go in
but my question is was when when the
Iraq War started there's protest
everywhere when Barack Obama decides to
invade Syria ain't nobody says anything
right nothing Donald Trump comes in
tries to get the troops out they lie to
him to keep the troops in right this is
it's it's crazy they at this point and
so now with the bombing campaign in Iraq
and Syria we've basically got a
unilateral declaration of war on Syria
we're attacking Iranian uh uh uh linked
targets whatever that means it's just
there's not going to be any formal
Declaration of a World War II or
expansion of War we're just slowly
walking our way into further and further
escalation on top of that everyone was
has been sharing this video from
December 4th of C-SPAN of Senator Dick
Durban saying we should make illegal
immigrants uh uh soldiers we should
bring them in I mean this is C-SPAN
right here dick Durban wants to make it
possible for illegal immigrants to join
the US and I be getting a bunch of
people messaging me being like that's
exactly how the Roman Empire collapsed
yeah I mean I remember were we did IRL
the day he did this and uh Kingsley
Cortez was here and we had the same
reaction which was that you can't have a
bunch of people who don't have a tie of
this country come in and fight for you
because ultimately their loyalty is to
the federal government it's not to the
culture or the people or the states and
that is dangerous for the population
that potentially could resist the
federal government it's it's such a
ridiculous suggestion but it's obviously
been on the minds of senators in this
country for a long time again to me that
speaks that they are not ultimately
loyal to the people that they serve
they're they're loyal to power and
controlling the masses yeah it's kind of
like the new form of DACA right this is
the this is the way we get more migrants
into our country we let them serve serve
in our military and then we give them
citizenship say Well done now you can go
to college on the GI Bill and then
you'll be sufficiently roped in and
hopefully support Democrats so do we see
this Administration going around and
rounding up the illegals to and giving
them guns and sending them away and if
they refuse we that Administration
deports them like how does it look I
just don't think they get organized fast
enough right like the reality is that
he's uh going into somewhat of a lame
duck period I mean we've got to November
we expect a wave of executive actions at
the or orders at the end of the year but
like I just don't know the thing is like
one of the reasons that we can't find we
don't know the true number of how many
illegal aliens are here is because they
AR are unregistered so how would the
government you know round up enough of
them they'd have to they'd have to put
out a call and most immigrant groups
like all of the NOS or nonprofits that
support illegal aliens in this country
they always say like if police come to
your door don't answer and you know
resist that so actually there's now a
problem like you can't get them to come
out and the propaganda the propaganda is
crazy there is this viral uh meme I
guess going around it statistics on
crime and it's like some guy being like
just going to drop this here and it says
native born Americans crime is really
high undocumented immigrants is low and
then immigrants is super low and I'm
just like my guy the crime rate for
illegal immigrants is at least one: one
like quite literally you can't it's
impossible to claim native born citizens
commit more crime as opposed to
quotequote undocumented immigrants
because they started off by committing a
crime which means literally every single
one of them right has committed a crime
not every single native born citizen has
committed a crime right they're at 100%
right off the bat that crime doesn't
matter though that's that's not a real
crime that's just Civil Disobedience
right but but it is and they exclude it
when it's literally a crime to to
illegally enter the contct illegally
it's a crime we we exclude all kinds of
crime as long as you take down the right
statues or as long as you take out you
know storm the right office or desecrate
the right government building if you're
doing the thing we want you to be doing
then we're okay with it I love the meme
that they someone made recently where
it's the guy on January 6 with his feet
on the table and it's not even a funny
meme it's just like years in prison and
then it's the photo of the guy having
gay sex in the Senate building and it's
like no charges no evidence it's crazy
and they expect everyone to just go
along with it like that's they said
there's no evidence of a crime like
there's no evidence of a crime the only
reason we know it happened is because
there's a video that went viral like
what are you talk what if they actually
did bring charges against the people
involved and it actually went to court
in washon DC would they be convicted cuz
you know how cops work they only charge
when they feel like they can get a
conviction right so I'm so over this man
like there's a there's a video out of
Boston of a bunch of cops standing
outside of the community center in the
black neighborhood where they were
housing all the criminal aliens and
there's a black dude screaming like I
can barely afford to live I work 40
hours a week and I can't even go to my
community center anymore and the cops
are like GTFO and I just it's just I
love it man I tweet FD these cops
scumbags and I get these conservative
Blue Line people being like Tim it's not
the police offer officer's fault it's
not their fault I'm like it's dude it's
nobody's fault but the person who
committed the crime okay like some some
guy you've never heard of in an office
somewhere you've never been to it's the
real criminal what are you talking about
I'm watching a guy work like work with
criminal aliens right here like just how
Wild would it be if somebody is like in
the middle of beating a child and you're
like well hold on hold on who told him
to do it I'm like I don't care dude stop
the person those cops are committing
crimes no but they were told it's not
legal dude and that's where we're
currently at where I just see everything
man I think we got cultural victories
and all that stuff but man it does feel
like things are falling apart because
you got every man for himself mentality
it's like watching the cops not do
anything for the riots like in the city
to standing by meanwhile when they were
told to go arrest people trying to have
prayer service in a park in the city you
know they would do that or yeah
arresting the people wearing the mask or
not wearing the mask it's less likely
the people praying are going to resist I
mean they're expecting the certain
people to comply and I find that that's
sort of an insult I mean we talk about
it a couple days ago on the show but
older Generations are more likely to
trust media they more likely to trust
the federal government and so in some
respects like the the thing that makes
them vulnerable to being arrested by
police is the fact that they want to
comply with the system they want to be
supportive whereas the police are like
well that seems so crazy over there I'm
not sure what we can do so we just won't
like that seems like an insult to people
who are ultimately trying to live by the
rules of Law and Order yeah so the
authorities just go after the people who
are easy targets yeah c afraid of the
riots and they're afraid of the Public
Image can we just like I I know well
probably the bureaucracy within the
department that's usually what kills any
sort of impetus to do something virtuous
is I will lose my job and my wife and
kids are going to suffer and I'm going
to lose my pension and so I'm not going
to do that you should quit then you know
part part of me is glad we haven't seen
a lot of that have we like you lose your
Pion cops being like I'm done and I
think yeah victim to theseion we've seen
a lot of it actually New York massive uh
all over the place uh I think you know
at one point a few years ago during the
defund the police Movement we were
looking at more than half of like
departments had seen you know
resignations resignations sick outs yeah
a lot of cops were just like I won't do
this anymore there's even a viral video
where a cop in Seattle is like stopping
at a light and all the activists are
screaming and laughing at him and he's
and he yells you won you won you win I'm
out I quit yeah and then everyone
they're all laughing they're like we got
them I'm just like what I was gonna say
is I'm glad those the police are
refusing to charge the guys who had the
gay sex in the Senate building cuz I
just want everybody listening to bring
that conversation up to your uh liberal
friends and family members just bring it
right up and when and just like I'm
sorry like when they're like well you
know I'll be like dude come on there's a
video a viral video literally of a
Democrat Senator staff member getting
banged in the Senate building and they
won't criminally charge him you you you
you want to come to me you want to come
to me and tell me that the machine's not
biased come on have we seen any people
defend that like I haven't evening from
he put out a statement being like I'm
being persecuted because of who I love
and so immediately they super impose me
man that's why that's why we can't let
it go yeah that's why because if you
notice all of the prominent leftists
will not bring it up mhm so everybody
should just keep talking about it and it
took like 36 hours for it to puncture
through mainstream I think think Fox was
one of the first people reporting it but
again it wasn't that much I mean the
story is crazy typically what they say
is sex cells and in case in this case
it's like no one talk wrong kind yeah
not this one we don't like this one we
we did the culture War episode maybe the
day or two after that happened and we on
the show looked it up in the news and
there were no reports on it at all cuz
it broke on a Friday I'm pretty sure and
like by Saturday was when I was starting
to get news alerts about it but like of
course I had like it is one of those
things that reminds you that Twitter is
a very different space than the story
yeah was it the Daily Caller Daily
Caller did yeah yeah they've been
getting yeah yeah let's jump to this
story we got this from The Daily Mail
National Guard would be able to use
Force against armed migrants entering
the US under new bill from Navy SEAL
veteran Republican Congressman they
going to mention that House Republicans
are pushing a bill that would authorize
the National Guard to use lethal Force
against individuals with weapons
Crossing from Mexico into United States
they do they do keep saying that but
they also mention the bill actually says
and for other me other uh uh other
issues or whatever they say in the last
year there have been multiple instances
of migrants Crossing into the US
carrying weapons with some brand
brandishing rifles like an AR-15 as the
B Administration in Texas governor Greg
evot Clash over border security policies
the bill Latrell claims will enable the
National Guard to better protect the US
by using any means necessary to stop
armed migrants look they got photos of
these dudes that's kind of that's kind
of wild I just came believe that we have
to pass this law what what are we even
doing this whole time it's legit an
invasion I know they're coming armed why
are we not just the headline should to
say Invasion at the border well of
course they won't who who wrote this
assist here you go they call him the
people Smuggler oh that sounds like a
super villain name the people Smuggler
was filmed by Texas department of safety
drone on Wednesday near Eagle Pass this
is Wednesday take this photo post it on
Twitter and say Invasion okay spare me
these dudes are coming with right rles
and our our guys aren't even allowed to
defend this country from armed people
wow again why does this have to be a law
I just don't get this I I I mean I'm I'm
glad it is if no one has thought that
this is something that's necessary why
do we have a border if we're not trying
to stop people who are entering armed
who are trying to enter illegally wall
armed like again what are we doing here
team well what are we doing s why are
these Governors sending the national
guard down there if they are aren't I
didn't know they're not allowed to use
their weapons against put out their arms
and be like go
back hold hands and sing so I'm so glad
that Ronda Sanchez and every all these
Governors are sending more and more
National Guard troops because what are
all they can do is just build fences and
say please right they're going to link
arms and just be like you cannot cross
they're not allowed to you shall not
pass they're not allowed to retaliate
having been to the Border in Yuma and
seeing how they treat people coming
across the border with like luggage tags
and van rides and plan tickets and stuff
I wouldn't be surprised if they come
with the gun be like do you need more
ammo like where you is everything okay
do you need a case for that rifle
totally crazy where hey where did you
get that did you that that come from
here did you is interesting to me so
there's this well and then there was
another one that the house passed
yesterday um saying I I have to remember
uh I should have give this guy credit
but I can't remember his name uh
basically oh it's um Barry Moore from
Alabama I think he proposed this bill
that if you if there's an illegal
immigrant who's in the country and gets
convicted of or admits to driving while
intoxicated DUI then that's ground that
makes them inadmissible so they couldn't
get like a green card they couldn't get
any status and also its grounds for
deportation which when I read it it was
sort of like yes of course because
you're here illegally in the first place
already committed a crime and then you
commit another crime seems like you
should definitely go but the fact that
we have to spell this out clever
politics it's like let's just pick one
crime that everybody can sort of gather
around like it seems it also seems
reasonable like someone who commits a
crime while in the process of committing
another crime being here illegally right
probably I don't want them to be a
citizen probably they are not here with
good intentions yes like it seems basic
and obvious but at the same time 150
Democrats in the house voted against it
right like it is weird that we have to
say this is a bad idea and in fact there
were congressmen from every border state
you know California New Mexico Arizona
who are Democrats who voted for this so
it makes me wonder like are you seeing
this in your community where are people
who are here illegally and are
proceeding to you know potentially be
hazards to you know the illegal
population but also the legal residence
in this in in your in your communities
it's very weird at a certain point they
just can't deny it and their
constituents are like you our our places
are our homes are ruined this place is
ruined people are leaving the economy in
this town or city is is dying uh like we
see with Eric Adams when he spoke out
but then once he spoke out wasn't he
they tried to meet to him like a week or
two later oh yeah that kind of
disappeared for a while didn't he was
getting hated by the feds wasn't he yeah
he was jeez man we're at the like this
is the 11th hour dude we got like can we
pull up this picture again my friends
it's not the only one he's hanging out
in the trees over here bro this is an
invasion it's like this guy's got a gun
and and and apparently it's an issue
they're like maybe we should give the
National Guard the ability to like I
don't know fight back when they're being
shot at or something watch him he's a
poor Asylum Seeker he's just trying to
you know come for opportunity hands up
don't shoot it's it's xenophobic it's
xenophobic to question armed Asylum
Seeker
I'm actually totally down for saying
Asylum they're ready to go to war Tim
just like you've been saying he's like
dick deran I'm coming I'm ready to F
here I'm here to sign I'm here to sign
up and Fight for Uncle Sam they're like
this guy's got experience no the left
likes to call them all Seekers even when
they're their criminal aliens or
Smugglers or whatever and so then you
get the right saying illegal immigrant
and I'm telling people like Criminal
Alien is the legal term for this I'm
going back to Asylum Seeker cuz I'm
going to say armed Asylum Seekers yeah
mostly peaceful mostly peaceful yeah
buted possibly
peaceful he loves the Second Amendment
of course he's an American hopefully
peaceful this is kind of wild and this
is I mean I wish I had listened to a a
Kent jpierre White House briefing today
I'm sure if she saw this was asked about
it she be like everything at the border
is fine every don't question this at all
like at what point this is for the
hardcore Progressive Democrats I don't
know that anything on this level will
convince them but people who are sort of
non-political moderate maybe lean a
little socially left when you see these
pictures at what point are you just like
yes this is incorrect no no no if you
take a closer look and you zoom in you
can actually see there's something on
the back right he's holding a small
Anvil of course he's trying to set up a
smithing shop right stop assuming these
are criminals oh I don't know it almost
looks like a bump stock to me I the
thing is Wy coyote use anvils all the
time for bad things and so I just that
sounds counts as a weapon to me too
clear to your point it's like those
people those very same people you're
talking about looking at this and
thinking that they might come to terms
with it the reality of it they're the
ones who looked at the riots and thought
they were just see I think that shifted
I think there are I think there's been
sort of a bleeding effect away because
some of these things are so concrete and
that's why I think a lot of progressive
Outlets a lot of progressive activ harp
on January 6 so much because it's a way
to sort of quell the fear like you can't
question anything that's going on
because ultimately look at this very bad
thing theoretically that happened this
one time whereas this is an active
Invasion that's going on constantly and
in fact has been going on for 3 years I
mean it's what the the official number
is something like we think six million
IM illegal criminal aliens are here but
when Ronda Sanz was doing his uh uh
press conference when he was saying I'm
going to send people to the Border he
was like what's the number like 10
million no one knows how many of these
people are here there's no way of
knowing did you see the Theo Van's tweet
I think it was last weekend he the best
he tweeted um let's what was it like
let's close the get a head count on
who's in this
MF I'm not doing it justice he had
another re one too I forget he had a
bunch of good ones he's so funny until
we can figure out what's going on you
know Charlie as the uh resident kamla
expert what's her Take On the Border
wasn't she our borders are she supposed
to be in charge of the Border well go
back to I think it was in June 21 when
she went to Guatemala and she held that
press conference and she got real Stern
and said do not come that's right do not
come remember angered AOC and a lot of
other other progressives well I guess
they're not listening to KLA but why
would they not listen to KLA I've heard
that she's very influential she's
historic I don't know why they didn't
get the memo why did they make her
borders are does your does your book
know yeah it's kind this is kind of uh
this was kind of Biden's first uh
attempt to be like all right kamla
you're my buddy vice president you're
going to take one for the team here's
what we did I'm putting you in so I
always wondered if that was him sort of
being like I'm going to give you a bad
job J because I don't really like you I
don't want you to be more like
successful than I am and he knew exactly
what he was doing cuz Obama did the same
thing to him Charlie I got to stop you
there though when has anyone ever said
that Biden knows exactly what he's doing
sorry maybe in the first few months of
his first term okay okay as what vice
president as president well at least his
team knew right because he's had the
same team for decades we've heard
stories I got them from Obama I heard no
they're his guys they're team Biden is
very strong and very powerful and they
are not beholden to anybody else but
their own interests like they aren't
even beholden to the Biden family at
this point it's just them so why did
they want if he was immediately going to
stick her with a terrible job trying to
reign in the Border not really though if
you're a Democrat why did he select her
as VP like if there's always been a
little bit of tension there was it just
that she would bring him the
demographics he wanted as I outlined in
the book it was a very political
decision he actually preferred Gretchen
Whitmer CU you know she's mid Western
swing state she campaigned on the idea
of fixing the damn roads you know fed's
Lover he liked that he lik he liked her
style of politics and thought she was a
real winner she actually tried to drop
out of the running because you know the
whole the whole process was sort of
overrun by the George Floyd riots It's
like got very volatile and that's when
everyone sort of started dropping out
you had Amy cloa Char just be like oh I
gotta go former prosecutor right in
Minnesota so I like I'm not I'm not I'm
not doing this so you saw more and more
candidates drop out and so he ended up
but he had to pick up you know he had
vowed to pick a woman vice president and
then ultimately it was clear by you know
the senior advisers that he had to pick
a woman of color during this time of you
know racial tension and he was not doing
so good on racial issues he was going
around saying you know poor kids are
just as just as smart as white kids and
you're not you're not black if you vote
for Trump and so yeah he really had to
show that part of his base that he was
serious about hearing them and getting a
woman of color on the ticket you know
you know what I was thinking it's like
it's really funny how the left says
these Christians are all super hateful
and all that and I'm thinking this
because I'm like you know I blame for
all of the stuff happening right now
like where we are in my generation I
blame Christian conservatives and it's
because they're too good of people and
they were very tolerant and accepting to
so many really bad people that they kept
acting in good faith and allowed these
far LEF as and communist to infiltrate
institutions so I mean that somewhat I'm
half joking right but uh you know 30 40
years ago you like or 50 60 years ago
when you have a very Christian
conservative Nation evil steps in lies
and being good people they're like well
you know I think we should give these
people a fair chance and now you've got
Communists running over everything and
even to this day the Republican party is
still impotent and won't address these
things I mean Donald Trump gets sued
criminally charged charged abused
mercilessly in these jurisdictions not a
single Republican jurisdiction is
countering I mean maybe there's one or
two small ones here there but where's
West Virginia or or Texas Ken Paxton
should file criminal charges against Joe
Biden for facilitating human smuggling
why why not I mean the charges against
Trump are are ludicrous he did not lead
an Insurrection okay Ken Paxton file
charges against Joe Biden right now for
leading an Insurrection at our Southern
border use that photo and let them argue
he's immune whatever he will have to
answer to the Texas legal system but you
know what as much as Texas is the stand
Standing your ground and all that stuff
I know the judges there going to go oh
gez all well you know we can't do that
I'm like dude are you watching what
they're doing in New York but we are
better men okay well then Trump goes to
prison have a nice day yeah it does seem
like they need to become more of an
offense uh right now it does feel like a
lot of states are just on defense are
kind of waiting to respond to what more
Progressive activists are doing um but I
don't I'm not enough of a legal expert
to know what what steps should be taken
I think it would just be good for
conservative voters to see action taken
so I tweeted that eege Carroll was a
deranged I'll just say person it was a
bit more it was it was a bit more uh
aggressive than that and I got all these
leftists this one went viral and it was
like Hey I'm Tim P I'm going to defame a
woman who just won a massive defamation
lawsuit and I'm just like for one I did
not def her I insulted her there's a
difference two this is not how the law
works you people are morons however Fair
Point people like this are in law in New
York and they're like we'll do it anyway
and so when the question comes up as to
what are the legal requirements for Ken
Paxton and Texas to actually bring about
some kind of charges or to to uh I don't
know if he would be the actual guy to
bring the charges or how he could pursue
this it doesn't even matter you look at
what's going on in in New York and it's
all fake and we all know it mhm come on
right single Republican in any
jurisdiction do I have to run for office
I swear I swear I might have to you guys
make Tim run for office he'll be real
mad I'm going to be really mad but I'll
run for some office where I'm like I
don't care what it is I I will take a
sheriff's office and I will immediately
be like I am going to go and start
arresting people who are breaking the
law like that's it like in West Virginia
they should have a criminal
investigation right now into this
Customs and Border Protection facility
it's a massive facility on 340 in West
Virginia there should be state state law
enforcement raiding that building with a
warrant from a judge because we want to
know what's going on with their internal
Communications as per the human
smuggling they're involved in Ain't
nobody got the balls to actually do
anything though yeah think sorry do you
think it's because they're spineless or
they're or they're uh like stalled by
their fear of these institutions see I
always wondering if it's similar to The
Fear like if you are when the federal
government investigates itself it's
always like we've done nothing wrong
everything's good right so like with the
um DOD probe into Lloyd Austin
hospitalization and like the fact that
he didn't tell anybody and no one knew
like he when he did his press conference
he said you know there is an internal
investigation Congress has done some
stuff but ultimately if you're
investigating yourself you're going to
say it's okay so with like the custom
and border patrol it would be I assume
West Virginia that needs to come in and
say we're investigating what's going on
here but I've heard so often from law
enforcement oh well you know fed Trump
State the feds are allowed to do
whatever and I want to know is that
actually true or is this just the
attitude that has become that you think
that the federal government cuz Texas is
proving that wrong right now Texas said
our right to self-defense is the supreme
law of the land let me pull up this
story here from uh the post-millennial
big fans New York City to pay out $53
million on prepaid debit cards to
illegal immigrants in pilot program oh
uh so when Eric Adams comes out and says
this will destroy us he gets accused of
crimes and he gets raided the next thing
you know he's like I am going to give
$53 million to illegal immigrants I am
totally for this it's coming out of my
bank account too he's like blinking out
in moris code like I want to rescue me
no it's bad I think it' be funnier if
they spent $53 million to just ship them
to Eagle Pass at which point they're
escorted back across the border I I
genuinely think the Democrat strategy is
we have to destroy this country to the
greatest degree imaginable before Trump
wins because the only response we have
or I should say not the only but the
functional response the best course of
action is Trump wins so I think you you
know there's uh I just love all of the
articles that are popping up about
Taylor Swift I'm not going to get into
the whole thing about Taylor Swift my
point is this have any of the people
whove pushed that story stopped to ask
themselves why it is the corporate press
is running Full Speed Ahead pumping out
dozens of stories about the right
attacking Taylor
Swift they they they want you to they
want you to do this okay don't why is it
we look at
this I I I I think their their attitud
is like they're desperately praying some
rightwing Ora guy acts a fool mhm they
want they want some rightwing guy to act
out of line so they can use that and so
they're going to press and turn the heat
up in the pressure cooker as much as
possible 53 million of your money going
to illegal immigrants the Border crisis
like the CBP cutting border barrier
razor wire like why are they doing this
obviously they want to destroy the
country but I think they're trying to
force or actually create the
circumstances where they can at least
claim the right engage in some kind of
violence I think we're we're seeing this
like sustained absurdity and it's and
they're becoming very desperate and uh
this is about to be dark so if you have
little ones listening uh it's dark but
this is how I've been thinking about the
government lately in terms of their
desperation I think of Ted Bundy and how
Ted Bundy operated secretly for years
you know doing horrible things and his
last Act of desperation when they were
on to him went on a horrible murder
spree you know and it seems like with
this kind of sustained absurdity and and
violence and the war on every front
possible it seems like you know I think
of the government like Ted Bundy in that
last desper act it may be like for him
he said oh no they're going to catch me
I better get as much as I can in for the
Democrats and the uni party I think
they're
thinking we like Trump is going to
reverse whatever it is we do let's so so
imagine it this way let's say there's a
scale of uh zero to 100 and they're like
if we're at 50 Trump is going to pull
them pull us back to 20 we need to push
things to 100 so Trump can only go back
to 70 so it's like they know that
Trump's going to deport a million
migrant the left Works destroy
everything Trump's going to deport a
million migrants let's bring in 10
million so he can only Deport one out of
the nine we got in it's a big ask like
in terms of yeah policies and it has two
effects number one they can run
screaming with all these headlines being
like how could he do this he's deporting
poor Asylum Seekers and etc etc and also
they can then say and he didn't even do
that good of a job there are so many
more people here he didn't come through
with his promises like there's trying to
set him up to fail on two fronts which
is crazy it's the inverse of what Biden
did with the economy coming back after
uh Trump locking it down so they keep
claiming all these jobs came back but
they came back because we took them away
right and then they spin that as a
positive for Biden so it'll be the
inverse of that for Trump when they make
it they wreck this country so much and
it's like almost impossible to bring it
back to the way it was you know but I
think we're missing the bigger point is
like Joe they're now trying to set up
Joe Biden as a wartime president you
know single-handedly La pressing the
buttons of hundreds of missiles into the
Middle East meanwhile he's back in bed
in Delaware I think right now right and
like he SP most they released like a
three paragraph statement and typically
the president supposed to get up there
and give a speech to explain to the
American people now it's just autopilot
I don't think they're trying to make him
a wartime president because like I like
you said he should be up there standing
giving speeches and he's not I think
there it's part of the big we call the
big act not the big ask where they're
saying if Trump gets elected he's
pulling our troops out of all these
places let's scattershot the Middle East
forcing military action on the United
States that Trump could never even pull
back from so bring in 10x illegal
immigrants so Trump can only Deport half
of them go to war as much as possible in
the Middle East so that Trump will
struggle to get our troops out they're
just trying to create the biggest mess
for Trump to clean up so it looks like
he's not succeeding no no they're trying
to get four they're trying to get eight
years of the presidency in four years
crazy so that when Trump goes in and and
actually I say 12 years because Trump's
going to reverse four years of their
actions they want eight they want 2020
to 2028 everything they want illegal
immigration War conflict crisis if Trump
is minus four years they need to do 12
12 years of this policy happening in
four years and that makes sense if you
think about it 10 million illegal
immigrants in in in in the span of a
couple years right if they had if they
had the uh if they had the white White
House up until 2028 they can be like
well we can sustain it slowly but they
genuinely think Trump's going to win
most people think Trump's going to win
so they're like we have to Triple our
efforts so that Trump can only pull back
a little bit but that allows them to
accomplish their goals from now until
2028 yep I I've been calling them uh
these things in the sto in the in the
media like invisible landmines where
there's something that you know that the
all the migrants are criminals fugitives
The Invasion is happening and then
they're filling the country Trump takes
over then they him into the bad guy by
saying look at he's doing all these
crazy things he's he's deporting
everyone he's the monster we always told
you he was they're going to show
pictures of him like people are being
loaded into trucks and buses and they're
going to say we said never again but
it's happening now yeah think of all the
New Yorker covers they're going to paint
him you know looking like like Hitler
and whatnot but well maybe he should be
more strategic maybe just uh start by
deporting the child molesters and the
drunk drivers that but that's not going
to matter for the
photographers right it's not going to
matter for the photographs and the
propaganda MH right so the smart play is
that he has to deport them in a way that
makes it difficult for them to run that
narrative and I actually think that
hopefully conservative media gets out
with him because I think that's part of
it they they can't back down and use the
terms they have to be honest about the
fact that these people are always here
illegally and they're not supposed to be
here I no I think the the the answer I I
brought this up the other day is uh
Donald Trump gets in immediately goes I
agree with dick Durban we're going to
bring them into the military a good and
women in uniform and then you take all
the illegal
immigrants you you you with handshakes
and a salute we're like you're come into
basic training and then through all this
you know with they'll post a photo on a
magazine being like Trump is in listing
illegal immigrants I guess it's like
well it's a Democrat idea and they may
try to spin it but then what you what
you do is
you you hold on hold on you deploy them
wink oh ah all right so what country are
you from sir I'm from Honduras
congratulations you're being deployed to
Honduras you don't need a gun or a
helmet here's that like more expensive
route to do this but we're going to
we're going to send you to the other
side of the border to guard the Border
we'll take the M that's a good idea stay
over there don't let anybody in wait
that's a good idea actually you're all
being deployed to line the Border uh
don't let anybody in who needs a wall we
have a human wall if anybody gets in
none of you get citizenship
yeah if you can hold it for a year but
then the best part but the best part is
we can promise them anything and like
the US government already treats its
veterans they just abandon them yeah
right we give you nothing there you go
it's like uh I served for four years
it's like do you notice the the line of
all the other veterans that we've
ignored man you should have read the
fine print I think that's true maybe
this is the way to solve this issue I
was skeptical at first because it seemed
like we'd just be using taxpayer money
to do something crazy but well it is
that's the only way to secure the Border
but then but then the media is like
Trump is loading up all these people on
the buses and trains and then he's like
but yeah because they chose to join the
military cuz they're good people why why
would you insult them like that oh geez
and of course the training camp is a new
training camp we set up in um southern
Mexico this is getting very Roman Empire
riew I mean that's what you could do
like basic training for all uh
non-citizens who want to enlist we uh
well that that training camp is not in
the United States it's uh you know in
Guatemala right we exported our training
facilities to Mexico it's cheaper there
just like our manufacturing job we're
saving money for everybody yeah yeah and
then we just you know your your your
your job is to guard the training camp
and they all just stay there problem
solved be interesting but yeah you'll
need Creative Solutions otherwise
they're going to run this narrative
Donald Trump is Hitler I mean I gota be
honest like they've already run that
narrative ad nauseum yeah they'll add
photos to the mix I wonder if at that
point everyone's going to be like just I
just don't care anymore you know like
aathy Central well no look I mean this
might be the best thing in the world for
Trump trump finally gets in actually is
loading people on buses and trains and
sending them off to be deported and the
media screams he's Hitler and at that
point you're like I get it the sky is
falling and there's wolves I don't care
I'm so over it well I think the thing is
if they run the pictures of trump
loading people up on buses because you
know why would he Deport people who are
illegally apparently that's the wrong
thing to do I think hopefully
conservative media Gets behind him and
and runs the photos of every person who
has been killed by someone who was here
illegally I mean there are already
resources that do this border Hawk does
this D Dan Lyman there are people who
suffer because of imigration not just
the economic effects but like the crime
if you showed all the footage of the you
saw this the trash and like the
underwear that's at the border right
there's horrible things there's evidence
that something is wrong and we just
don't show those pictures enough it's
that like republicans in Congress the
media that supports Trump or the
influencers let's say the the spokes the
the talking headset to it need to be
just as on the offense I I think I
figured it out I know what we need you
guys remember that article where it said
it was like um Trump ends up supporting
lockdown so that everyone opposes or
something like that what we need is 5D
chess where Trump gets elected but keeps
doing everything the Democrats want to
be done and so they have no choice but
to oppose all of it so but here here's
prepaid debit cards pilot program that's
first action bus Donald Trump gets in
and he's like we're going to open the
Border let everybody in and the
Democrats are immediately like uh we got
a bill through Congress and no more
border and he's like I guess I have to
sign it and then he signs it and then
he's like we're going to send all our
troops to to Iran like no no we you
can't do that yeah Trump's a fascist
like oh jeez I guess I got okay no
troops to Iran that might be the only
way to do it because the Republicans
even when we had he had Congress and
Senate in that first two years not much
was done and and the Democrats do
mobilize you got to trick them do you
feel like the there's been a changing of
the guards in that in the house and in
in the Senate with the Republicans that
are there I feel like after the last
year we've really seen a sort of uh
Clashing of old and new I would say just
seems like it's fractured like it hasn't
coalesced on anything just like you know
right-wing Twitter at times you know
there's
no in the Senate you have Mitch
McConnell and he doesn't I don't imagine
he'll be sticking around if Trump wins
again he alive as I think that's when he
bows out and then it's to who John th
John baraso who else is in leadership I
I I think we're just it's unfortunate
but conservatives are to demure across
the board like the left will line up as
enemies to whoever is declared the enemy
you like some leftist activist can come
out and say I think X is a bad group of
people and they all just immediately
fall in line you literally have police
officers guarding criminal aliens
occupying a a building and I got tons of
Thin Blue Line or like back to Blue guys
being like no I defend the cops and I'm
like you know the cops are the ones who
are burning your neighborhoods down and
you're smiling and saying it's it's not
their fault okay dude I I I don't know
like culturally I see a bunch of
Victories budlight sponsoring Shane
Gillis is hilarious and I do think we're
winning but you know it is a challenge
and perhaps we could mitigate some of
the damage if we had more balls and more
willingness to call out bad people so
six wasn't the right play is that what
you're thinking yeah definitely not I
think the right play is
like every single conservative should be
completely aligned with if police
officers are facilitating human
smuggling they are they are opposed to
those police officers but we there's so
many people on the right who are like no
I don't blame the guys who are
committing the crime it's the person who
told them to do it and I'm just like I
both of them I don't care but like if we
went if these cops in Boston knew that
if they were filmed doing this they
would never eat another hot dog again
they would never be able to get a hotel
room no one would make them a
cheeseburger they wouldn't do it and so
what the left does this is funny when
these cops are in New York and the left
is trying to protest the left will film
them and be like yeah we're going to
film you the cops are like I don't care
you are Fringe nobody's you are not my
community I I don't care if the
conservative back the blue people did it
they'd start sweating bullets because
these are the people who actually live
in your neighborhoods and you're going
to walk in and be like aren't you that
guy that I saw helping criminal aliens
take over some town you think you can
eat food in my Resturant out of here
dude but conserves are like I don't
blame you it's not your fault yeah there
will always be that big that deep
respect for Law and Order and it's kind
of baked in conservatives but but like
but right but I understand what you're
saying you're saying that conservatives
are not actually respecting Law and
Order they are defending criminals
because the criminal has a badge and I
want to make sure this is clear I'm
going to talk about a Cop who's like
walking down the street and he's like
break up the fight guys I'm talking
about cops who were ordered to
facilitate human smuggling and they're
like you got it boss and they went there
and they're like I'm going to guard a
bunch of criminal aliens who have taken
this community center from these people
cuz my boss told me to do it and I'm
like well you're a criminal you you have
broken the law you should be arrested I
have no respect for you I think a lot of
them are afraid to sound like you know
riers during BLM and they're
overcompensating for how that looked you
know when that whole thing played out
but then I would remind people look at
the cops who went in and RI people out
of stadiums that weren't wearing a mask
yo the there the the there was a sheriff
a woman was in Minnesota and she tried
opening her Cafe during lockdown and so
they put out a warant for arrest or
whatever so she fled to Iowa and the
sheriff's hunted her down they were like
we're going to make sure this old ladyy
suffers man there were so many instances
where cops were just brutalizing regular
like my favorite is the New Jersey cops
a woman was live streaming she had a
store and she was live so she would sell
things you could come and buy stuff it
was like a resale shop when they shut
everybody down they're all closed so
what did she do she started live
streaming on Facebook saying here are
the things that I have let me film them
for you and you can order them on the
site and I'll ship them to you cops went
to her store and said ma'am you need to
close your store she goes what are you
talking about I am closed I'm like no
stop filming and stop trying to sell
things proving it was never about the
pandemic they these were just dictators
and I'm it's remarkable that people were
like will I back the blue so well the
other weird thing that came out in the
beginning of the pandemic was that
domestic viol de violence weight I
cannot talk right now domestic violence
rates jumped significantly and so there
there are people that would have maybe
needed law enforcement's help that
probably didn't get it but then there
were businesses that were just trying to
find a way to make money potentially
keep their employees on and they got the
it's their livelihood right that's so
the store owners when your livelihood is
threatened that's when civil that's when
you're ready to just civil Civil
Disobedience when when it goes that's
when the conservatives like hey don't
threaten my
livelihood you know maybe that's what it
takes for the conservatives to turn on
law enforcement we didn't say there are
other things that are going on like
because we locked everyone in their
homes there are other social uh uh
issues that are coming up and we should
maybe use law enforcement to help with
those things instead it was like how do
we make everyone hurt economically and
then and then we had a lot of people
just had to quit or or were fired for
not getting the shot and so who was left
you know I want to I want to turn things
around we'll get a little too dark too
black Billy let's go white bill check
this out Wall Street Journal big news
ladies and gentlemen Joe Rogan gets new
Spotify deal worth up to $250 million
hit show to be distributed broadly
including on YouTube rather than
exclusively on audio audio streaming
service all right where we at this deal
is an upfront minimum guarantee what
does that mean it means Spotify told Joe
Rogan here's what we're going to do boss
we're going to take your show we're
going to put on all platforms forms
every single platform imaginable we're
going to pay you $250 million upfront
guarantee but we get to sell ads on all
your content on every platform and you
got to pay us back that 250 after that
we do arve share so his original deal
was he had an exclusive deal this is my
understanding from Wall Street Journal
he had an exclusive deal where they said
we're going to pay you what was like
$200 million so that your show is only
on
Spotify many people were speculating I
was talking to people in the in the
media industry and they were like you
think Joe's going to reup this deal and
now we got the news he's coming back to
YouTube he's coming back to all
platforms with Spotify in control of how
the ads are placed and generated because
uh Spotify I believe I believe Spotify
owns megaphone someone want you want to
Google that real quick and I'm pretty
sure they do and that is basically
YouTube's ad Network how you can autop
place ads this is what uh uh megaphone
does so if you're going to like put a
podast upload a podcast you put it there
then you can place ads just like on
YouTube YouTube so Spotify is basically
going Broad and they're saying like we
want your content everywhere the reason
this is good demonetization is no longer
a factor Joe Rogan in the news all the
time hosts a lot of politically spicy
things and edgy things Spotify with this
bet it's not so much that they're
they're predicting something but they're
setting something Spotify is a
juggernaut if they say Joe Rogan is is
is is working with us and we're going to
sell ads on his content demonetization
is out the window YouTube is not going
to demonetize Joe Rogan's Show when he
has Alex Jones on because Spotify is
going to be like that's my money and
Google my understanding is a is a is a
is a shareholder to some degree or
there's some connection there between
the two I think Google might have the
majority or something like that I don't
know long story short even if that's not
not the case Spotify does not want to
lose money they don't think they're
going to lose money and they're not
going to let these big companies take
their money from them by taking Joe
Rogan down which means we all get to
ride the coat Tales of Joe Rogan's show
it's not like you're going to get
absolute free speech on most platforms
but Joe Rogan's hosted you know
controversial guests and the media's
lost their mind over it now Spotify is
putting putting money behind it on
YouTube and all these other platforms on
every platform that's like we win dude
yeah this is like this is like the uh
inverse of John Stewart coming back to
the Daily Show that seems like a
desperate play for them to install this
guy to deceptively edit reality and try
to you just take the election uh but
this is like a big cultural you know
this is very impactful especially he's
going be back on YouTube during election
will it be election year do we know when
this starts I believe it's now I mean I
don't know when they're goingon to when
was it it was the end of 2020 they were
like January of 2021 or something he he
moved over wow so it's about time for
his contracts to expire Spotify uh
announced in 2020 that it was going to
acquire megaphone for uh $235 million
wow and then it looks like the deal
didn't finalize for a little while but
I'm pretty sure it went through are you
sure it it is finalized now it just
looks like it took like a year or two to
right on so how does this affect the
sort of the leftwing industry of getting
advertisers to
boycott um you know personalities and
then somehow that that chokes off their
revenue yeah I'm not really sure well
it's it's basically it's the end man you
think Spotify is is as as a major player
in the space is going to tolerate that
they're going to go after Joe Rogan
Google's going to start going and
Spotify is going to say don't touch it
mhm CU that's their money now it's not
yep you think they'll listen yeah Google
and well let's see I don't know if this
is uh I pulled it up in the spring of
2019 Google announced the acquisition of
the world renowned Swedish music
streaming service Spotify Google
believed acis in the world's most
popular service blah blah
blah did it actually they considered a
transaction amount to be quite
acceptable uh Spotify Google remain as
two independent companies in 2023 okay
so so it's not but I think basically
when you have major industry saying we
endorse this look at Dave Chappelle's
comedy you look at Bud Light sponsoring
Shane Gillis it's just like we're
winning the culture and the culture is
what leads to the politics like Donald
Trump getting elected is a component of
that when you look at all the things
that the left is doing the Democrats are
doing it's like they want to burn the
country down incite violence because
they're desperate it's like you were
saying about Ted Bundy like they the
walls are closing in man we're winning
everything do you think we we'll see a
trump on Rogan on
YouTube I don't know man it would be
epic it would be epic I you know bid's
not going to do it he can't sit in in
one place and talk for two hours his
face would fall off this is one of the
things I've started to start following
just for my own Amusement like he did
the National Prayer Breakfast or and he
spoke for 10 minutes and the year before
he spoke for 20 so it really is
dwindling how long he speaks so he
really I mean we've talked about this
with the the people who are running for
office right now uh V was really good
about this
RFK is on the podcast circuit uh they're
kind of embracing these alternative
platforms but this format of just
talking for several hours is not natural
to everybody and I really don't think
it's natural to Joe Biden not not even
on the people who are running uh on the
for the conservative ticket like d
santis haly couldn't do a podcast but
Trump is a complete natural for it I
mean he goes long on his speeches just
because he wants to anyways I mean he
could talk for three hours by himself
him and Rogan eating Trump steaks just
hanging out having a Trump Stakes I'm
pretty sure Trump Stakes still exist
right I have no idea I thought they were
done but they could no this is the thing
about uh this this what really you know
what you know what helped me be aware of
the lies about Donald Trump in the 20156
cycle I'm I'm at uh uh Fusion in uh D in
it's in Miami it's in Durell it's like
right next to Trump Durell Golf Resort
okay and so if I'm in New York and
everyone's saying oh Trump did this
Trump did that I'm like wow that's crazy
I'm like you know and I'm and I'm I'm
going on the ground I'm meeting people
and I'm like well that one doesn't seem
to make sense but then I go to Trump
Dural Trump Stakes available on the menu
Trump bottled water and Trump magazine
I'm I'm fairly certain it was all there
and I went oh Trump ice was that his
companies are like McDonald's makes
their own mayonnaise it's cheaper for
Trump to make a product internally than
it is to pay a premium to have another
company do it if Trump gets his stakes
from a a big stake company he's going to
be paying for their you know 10% margin
or whatever if he does it all on his own
as a trump stake he saves 10% when he
when he sources the materials for his
hotels and his Resorts yeah hotels need
uh bottled water they it's kind of a
microcosm of America first right always
buy from Trump yeah but then the media
kept saying that like his companies are
bankrupt and they were like you can't
even buy Trump sticks where are they at
and I was like huh they're right here
along with the taco bowl that's right
the taco bow I wonder if Trump Stakes
are still a thing no Trum Trump Stakes
are unfortunately not a thing they
stopped in 2007 which pains really but
I'm sure they're still on the menu I'm
sure like if you get a steak
at vertical integration going on there
it wouldn't not be so no this is also
isn't it not I feel like it' be normal
if if people shut down branches of their
business like this happens all the time
why fact that he even built a trump
steak brand is hilarious in the first
place is he not going to get credit for
that TR Stakes I don't know Tim you
might have something here Tim Stakes
they had Trump water and I I brought I
brought uh Trump water back to the
office in New York cuz they were all
saying that Trump water went out of
business and that Trump was bankrupt all
these companies and they loved running
this line where they were like Donald
Trump has been bankrupt five times how
is he still rich and well it's because
the banks are popping up it's because he
had 500 companies so 495 were fine and
the Trump organization was fine so I
come back and I'm like oh here's the
Trump water like where'd you get this
and I'm like from Trump Hotel like
literally next to the office in Miami
they were like wow I'm like these people
have no idea what's going on in the
world God look at that picture I just
want like a Sky Mall equivalent but it's
Trump related products like just Trump
mall and he just sells you like all
kinds of random things those have like
popped up independently all around the
country you know you'll see like this
like this like mainstream Wasteland and
then all of a sudden you'll see a store
that's just like the Trump store there's
a lot of them in Florida you'll see them
in like the middle of the country but
you'll just be driving along and then
you'll see just all of a sudden just a
window plastered with Trump
paraphernalia it's like a souvenir shop
for like the part ofer America that's
voting for him like this is amazing this
is crazy look at this in the Wikipedia
for Trump Stakes says in August 2015
Time Magazine included Trump Stakes on a
list of trump business failures in
December 2015 during the 2016
presidential campaign a super pack
supporting John Kasich produced an ad
mocking Trump Stakes blah blah blah I
don't care duden I should totally make a
list of my business failures yeah
there's a lot right I once worked on an
app to uh facilitate political donations
on Facebook for politicians and this was
like 200 9 or 10 or something very early
days it was like the app days of
Facebook and I was working with some
like how would anyone ever find out like
we worked on a project it went nowhere
we fizzled out we had like an early
prototype that couldn't really you know
then we were like ah we don't know
there's too much regulation let's do
something else the amount of things
Trump's probably worked on the funny
thing is they mock him for his failures
is it's a perfect perfect example of who
they are they have no failures they
think that's a good thing yeah but they
never tried to do anything they're Avers
to risk and they don't want to fail
to any work yes this is true that's why
they like the
pods I mean look let's let's let's let's
consider
this we put them in the pods they don't
mind we give them the bugs they also
don't mind who's complaining I don't got
to eat the bugs and I'm not going to
live in the Pod but they can I mean and
they're doing it give them the new Apple
headset
yeah this is my life plan right like
just let them go and I'll stay here and
if that's what you guys want to do cool
cool cool but I it is going in that
direction like the trend of a lot of
people growing up not having kids
they're just going to fizzle out and
also they're going to plug into the
neuralink and they're going to go to
their micro universes where they're you
know the Demon Slayer and you know they
got all the busty women jumping up and
down around them yeah funny because they
don't like Elon right now but they also
didn't like Trump but it was Trump's
vaccine but now they love the vaccine so
at some point they'll probably like the
neural like they didn't like elon's mete
CU that's how they that's their logic
yeah no but look how many of these these
liberal people have hidden their blue
checks on Twitter oh true why why sign
up for the service just to pretend like
you didn't sign up for it you know what
I mean because they're scared what a
genius move by Elon to just hide that
though it's like the best move give the
option you can hide your your
verification great move great move
that's crazy you want to be a coward you
can do it I think these people are going
to line up the left is going to line up
to jump into the into the Matrix with
with smiles on their faces it's it's
their entire Mo they're going to they're
and they're going to Advocate their kids
do it and they're going to you know what
you're you're better off
is bliss cure for depr juicy steaks how
could you be depressed right a clinical
uh um um hormonal depression I suppose
where you just don't understand why
you're you feel so your body doesn't
produce the correct amount of Serotonin
something like that but for the average
person their listlessness and depression
I love like the funny thing about Lauren
Southern had this tweet where she said
before we give you ssris you have to go
to the gym twice a week or something and
everyone's like you don't understand
some people and she's like I'm not
talking about people who are immobile
she like if you have the ability to go
to the gym go start working out it
releases endorphins it makes you feel
better what's going to happen is
someone's going to be like I'm depressed
like have you consider plugging in an
noral link and being being a a mini God
in your own Universe yep my friend uh
Joe Allen who's with the War Room went
to some Tech Convention recently and he
he posted a video of a new like type of
metaverse thing where you can plug in
you're like a little girl I'm like yeah
it's like they were like they was like a
I know I know and there was like a feed
that you put on your like a thing on
your mouth that I think wait wait wait
start over an adult man went to a
convention convention for adults
including adult M It's All Tech for all
new tech and there was one like Booth
sharing some new tech of like a
metaverse thing where you plug in and
you have the headset on and uh a mouth
thing over you so you can scream or be
loud and no one can hear you outside and
brought you into a you little and and
the character on the screen was like a
young girl so like they could sell it as
like look the transgender surgeries are
even cheaper in the metaverse well I
suppose it's like if someone made a
video game and it's like some old dude
plays it that's kind of creepy but I'm
not going to blame someone who made a
game with a character you know I think
it's weird because that's promoting like
you a lot of people can go into the
metaverse and now be these things that
they want to be think that's morally dud
this exists it's w no it exists already
so during the lockdowns uh we we still
have the Oculus nobody uses it but uh
shout outs to space pirate robot game
you ever play that one y that game is
amazing you're uh it's a VR game for the
Oculus and you're stand you you're St on
this big platform and there's robots
flying at you oh I've played this game
yeah it's so fun and you have like
different kinds of guns or an energy
sword and a shield and so I just love
whacking the robots it's so fun but
there's also a chat room function where
you go into this virtual reality chat
room and there's like a rabbit walking
around and there's like The Mad Hat
and there's just like you know a
crocodile dude and one guy's a carrot
and they're walking around and the guy's
like I identify as a carrot you like no
one really I'm kid no one really said
that oh so they're not in PCS they're
it's humans it's human beings in the
game walking around in their VR space
anate objects and you can like point the
stick and then teleport because you can
only move so far but this is what I was
saying like in the future you're going
to be in a business meeting and you're
going to like it's going to be
indistinguishable from reality you're
going to put on your headset or whatever
plug in your nurlink fall back and then
you're walking into the office you sit
down at the table and you got Mario to
your left you got you the Incredible
Hulk over here a giant cupcake with a
smiley face you don't even need an
electric car to get there no you just
teleport and the cupcak cupcake is going
to look at you with a big old smile and
go okay let's get into the TPS reports
our sales were down last week and and
nobody wants to buy anything new guy's
going to walk in looking just like a
human being and he's going to be the
only one he's going to be like am I in
the wrong room I'm like no no you're
here uh this is Jim he's been emailing
you he identifies as a cupcake oh okay
well okay great yeah my my brother is an
air like oh really you guys should talk
sometime a lot of comment yeah it's like
no the cop like actually a Claires are
very offensive to us it's like oh I
didn't know I'm
sorry I mean I do think that there will
be people who are interested in this and
in some ways this sounds more
entertaining than like endless Zoom
meetings if you work from home but I
just think it'll ultimately be one of
these things that like really splits
people and I think to your point from
earlier like people are already kind of
dividing up in the way they live we have
very separate Lifestyles going on people
who choose not to have children and are
maybe more like more into pursuing their
specific interests the metaverse might
be a great place because it makes
traveling cheaper because you just have
to plug in you don't have to buy a plane
ticket it makes you know something that
might physically risk you like if you
wanted to be a a great uh sky dier right
you don't actually have to do it you can
just get the thrill of doing it
virtually whereas there'll be people who
are like no I want to talk to people in
real life and I want to have kids and I
want to Bear responsibilities in a way
that you clearly don't want to they'll
just stop interacting I saw this uh real
on Instagram where someone was saying
like when you move different cities and
like one group of friends is talking
about settling down having kids the
other one is like I'm doing peyote this
weekend and I'm doing whatever like
there are just people who split and they
do different things and they live
different ways and they'll stop
intersecting at some do we take away
their right to vote or run for office if
they're in the metaverse only net
taxpayers can vote problem solved all
right there we go that solves all
problems if if you're a net taxpayer you
can vote have a nice day door dashes
just come out ahead because they will be
delivering food to all of the people
plugged into the mete those robots Fe
you cannot feed
people a f Tu like the Matrix got all
this wrong they they needed it because
there's no conflict without it but the
premise of the Matrix is that they gave
humans paradise and humans rejected it
because humans need conflict but there's
no reason to to create one Matrix each
individual person could be in their own
Matrix with experiencing their own
conflict and they would never have
Rebellion the machines would control
everyone because you'd be in your own
universe and they could make the
universe whatever you wanted it to be
kind of like a triming show more like
sort of but no one's really watching you
it's just to control you and you put
yourself there self-imposed Truman Show
and what if uh what if Sim so simulation
Theory what if it's
prison you are for like if if we get to
that point of neuralink someone commits
a crime they're going to say you are
sentenced to live a life in this way
through neuralink and so you know right
they take out your happy eurolink and
then neuralink and then they put in the
bad one well no they don't have to
change anything the neurolink is an
implant con you just Wireless connect to
it so some guy uh is driving his car and
he's drunk and he's like oh and then he
crashes and he kills some teenager and
they're like you're going to prison he's
like no and they're like we're going to
make you live a life as a parent who
loses a child in this way and you will
live in the in the that'll be your
punishment and the the sentence is only
like a week long but they put the in the
Pod crying they turn the thing on and
then he experiences 70 years of life as
growing up having a family raising a kid
kid's killed by a drunk driver he has to
live through it all and then he wakes up
like then he ages gets old dies and then
wakes up in the Pod like would we as a
society accept that as a punishment you
think the problem with United States is
that we went a little crazy with the no
cruel and unusual punishment thing and
uh it's a good thing but I mean we went
a little crazy with it in that like now
there's literally no instead of actually
trying to figure out ways to create
deterrence we just said put them in a
box and we've created gang Hangouts we
we've like just centralized gang
headquarters together yeah all it's and
it's like it is good we said no cruel
unusual punishment the problem is we
need to be more specific about what it
means to be cruel and unusual like our
punishments are completely uniform for
the most part and it's you go into two
box and then like people are getting
raped in there is that not cruel and
unusual it certainly is but we don't
care so we've uni like it's made this
uniform thing whereas like there are
means of creating uh penalties for
crimes that are better deterrence and
I'm not going to list a bunch but I'll
give you an example in I think it might
be like Switzerland if you're speeding
you have to pay a percentage fine so in
the United States you pay a dollar fine
I think it's Switzerland I'm not sure
but there's countries in Europe where
it's like okay your fine is you know 05%
of your yearly income based on your on
your past year's taxes and and that's
getting kicked in the balls if you're
making you know 20 million bucks you're
like oh man that's a fine but what
happens is like right now we're like
nope everybody's got to pay 50 bucks for
a parking ticket it's like okay for a
lot of people that's just paying for
parking so like uh Wrigley Field in
Chicago for instance people Everyone
Parks illegally because it's like I'll
get i'll get a $100 ticket cost 100
bucks to park yeah and so they're double
parked I remember cuz I used to live
there two blocks away and people would
double park down our street blocking our
cars in
wow and it's like we got to get them
towed get them towed and then what
happens when the people come out they
pay 200 bucks to get the car out of the
impound lot which is not that far away
and they're like okay they're like worth
it yep y because you can't park anywhere
else right it it's like you're driving
down Clark and there's a guy
service right and now you know where
your car is at you're like ah just want
I come out my car will be it'll be safe
in the in pound no one's going to break
in or steal anything so perhaps I'm I
I'm phrasing it wrong like we should not
allow cruel and unusual punishment but
we should allow for variety in how we
handle crime crimes yeah this is what I
found interesting about the nitrogen
hypoxygen in uh 2022 I think and part of
it was he had said you're not going to
be able to get a vein and it's going to
be uncomfortable for me and this is
cruel and you guys shouldn't make me do
this and eventually that was true it
didn't happen Alabama State executions
for months and during that time he was
like I want nitrogen hypoxide that's
what I want and Alabama is one of three
states where it's legal then later he
was like no there are too many risks
like I don't want to do this and
ultimately you know legal proceedings
the UN there was a commission there
being like it is it's human
experimentation you can't do this and
when he died you know you had some
Outlets that ran it that were like it
took 22 minutes this happen he struggled
well also there were reports that like
he refused he held his breath he didn't
want to breathe the nitrogen is coming
in just like during the lethal injection
there are reports that he that at one
point you have to clench your fist and
he wouldn't do it like ultimately this
person did not want to die which I
sympathize with except you were on death
row want to die quickly he wanted to
make it his and like you're on death row
for a murder so you knew this one was
coming uh only PC America is going to do
like oh how safe but this whole
conversation is like is this is nitrogen
hypoxia less cruel more cruel is it okay
to have other options because if you
can't get a vein on someone it takes
several hours to try and find one you
ultimately call it off that seems way
more cruel to me but what about just
like regular old hypoxia right why Nitro
it's nitrogen they just like nitrogen
deprives the oxygen from your body they
just fall asleep or what you fall asleep
and then eventually you go into organ
failure but you don't feel it because
you're a oh okay what's wrong with that
yeah he said that if anything were to go
wrong I could be a vegetable I could
risk a stroke which is like there are
risks to lethal injection too and then
one of his there were lots of things
that came up at last minute resistance U
he had a a spirital advisor who was who
filed a complaint saying Alabama must
made me sign this waiver that if
anything goes wrong if I'm within 3 feet
of him I risk exposure to this nitrogen
and you're stopping me from being able
to anoint him at death um so it's it's
just it's as we pl move forward with all
of these new technologies and all of
these new options we have to ask along
the way like is this experimentation is
it cruel and usual but also you have to
say like people who are delving into
this sometimes are just doing it to
avoid punishment here's here's the harsh
reality in uh Singapore I think it's uh
six canings you get you get can six
times yeah the canings are like
understand can it's like a it's like a
hard giant bamboo stick it's it's not
fun at all you pass out if you litter
they beat you yeah and so nobody litters
nobody choose gum do they do it publicly
I don't no it's not public it's not
public it's private thing so I'm against
the state being allowed to kill people
uh and so is one of my favorite writers
Albert Albert Camu is someone I love his
writing and uh he was also against the
state having the ability to kill people
however he made an argument in uh the
essay notes on a guillotine that if
we're going to do this it needs to be
very public to actually deter people
from doing it instead of doing it behind
closed doors no one knows aming I
actually don't think the death penalty
is a strong deterrent I think publicly
beating someone while laughing at them
would be there's a especially with a lot
of criminals having this like uh
especially in Chicago a lot of the
criminals are they want respect mhm
humiliating them in public would be a
deterrent for sure I'm not saying I
advocate for it I'm saying the guys that
I knew on the south side if they were
like if you get caught stealing we will
put you in a stock and spank you and
shame and shame you and make you wear a
diaper in public and take pictures and
post to the internet they'd be like I
ain't getting caught dude I doing that
nuts right I got a I got Connell in the
brain but she was that's what she did in
in California when she was a spank
people no well there was that Montel
Willam a little bit of uh trying trying
to humiliate well you know that the work
the work
having prison Crews fight wildfires and
then well that's SL that's not
humiliation they want that the people in
the prisons ask for that Duty because it
it gets them out yeah they get to go on
they get to go out they get to go on
rides they get paid a dollar an hour but
it's like it for it's compelled
servitude right no I'm I I'm I'm saying
like does speak for everybody but caning
in public would be a tremendous
deterrent I mean there's a reason why we
don't do it because it's so severe and
I'm not again not advocating for it but
that's the harsh reality is that places
like Singapore there's no gum on the
ground people don't Litter they're
they're because it like you will be
beaten we used to put people in stocks
here yeah what happened to that make
stocks great again yes make America
stock again s o c okay would you guys
would you guys support uh neuralink
prisons no I don't I think real life is
the real life and you have to be
punished in real life yeah I do too it's
like waking up from a dream you know
it'll affect you for a day perhaps I
also just don't trust neuralink at all
and so there's a level of I don't feel
like I can in good faith put someone in
nurlink prison if I also don't trust
nink at all I will let Elon experiment
on bad people per let's say you got
somebody like that was that was there's
one group that tried that was bad let's
say you got somebody who uh he's 20
years old and him and his buddies go
into a bodega and armed robbery steal
from the store clerk smash everything up
take all his money ransack the place and
then leave they get caught later and he
gets sentenced to four years in prison
for the armed robbery his sentence is he
will be placed in a neuralink where he
will wake up with the memories of a
store clerk owner and none of his past
life and he will experience having his
life savings and life destroyed in this
moment and then after that moment he
wakes up realizing what he did and how
they felt is that kind of like what they
were doing in Clockwork Orange when they
had the guy's eyes kept open and they're
showing him all the uh yeah but footage
actually having him experience the life
of you're a guy who saved up oh you know
he's like I'm working really hard my my
my my wife is sick I need to make money
and then yeah you come in Smash
something and destroy it all and then
they leave and you experience all of
that suffering I guess one of the things
that brings up for me is the idea
like in the neuralink are you able to
program someone's emotion cuz like if
you don't feel the guilt or if you don't
feel empathy really then going into
someone else's life and suffering like
would you experience the point like you
force them through that experience and
it's monitored and measured what if they
I'm just really worried about the amount
of power who's controlling the
neuralink yeah I'm just anti- neuralink
I think across the board uh about only
as uh only for the left yeah only for
people they want it like what if the
prisoners are like okay you can do this
one or you can go into the neural link
like do we want there like lethal
injection versus nitr hypox do we want
there to be options for people to choose
how they are punish what if we just say
we're going to we're we're going to send
you like you committed a crime you can
go to prison regular real life prison
for like Okay so this it's a serious
crime it's a negligent homicide you were
drinking and driving you killed two kids
you're going to get 10 years because
it's your it's your like third DUI you
weren't supped you didn't have a license
you're not someone who is like trying to
go out and kill but you've shown a
pattern of behavior and they say we're
going to do we're going to lock you for
lock you up for 15 years 20 years or nor
a link for life but nor a link happiness
you can go into this machine we remove
you from society because you're a danger
to society you will live a normal happy
life where you will feel good and you
will cause no harm to anybody I guess
that's the other question like is
imprisonment about separating people
from the population or is it about
Rehabilitation because there are other
countries that have different feelings
about this and I think it would be hard
to know it's supposed to be in the
United States the purpose of prison is
to uh unite gang members and Harden them
to worse criminals until there's a lock
down and then you release them all so
the crme they keep their populations
down it's it's just a calling Method Man
that's all it is but Shane what if one
day you're like on your deathbed your
family's all around you and then you're
like thank you for such a a good life
and they're like we love you we love you
and then you wake up and you're like
some 26-year-old gang banger who like
shot who shot an author who wrote weird
sci-fi
I I I would be extremely depressed I if
to wake up and and not have that family
well how do you wake up man true but
think about like you guys you ever
watched the Rick and Morty episode where
uh summer is in the car and Rick is like
protect summer and so it shoots a guy in
the spine at first it slices a guy into
cubes and she screams like don't do
don't kill people so then it paralyzes
the next guy and she's like stop hurting
people so then when the police show up
it it
genetically clones the son of one of the
police officers and the child comes out
and he's like Daddy and he's like oh my
God and he HTS his son but then his
son's like don't hurt the car dead he's
like what and then the kid melts and
he's screaming like think about the kind
of torture you could do to people with a
neuralink where you give them a child
and then force them to to live full
neuralink reality of watching their
child be murdered in front of them also
depends on the degree to which these
people can or have a capacity for
emotion cuz some of these Psychopaths I
don't know if it would work on them so
we were saying like you can make them
feel some emotions or whatever but I
don't think that's the point the point
is to get the person to feel those
emotions but then you have to get you
get the idea of yeah whether they can
feel those or if they're capable of
feeling it yeah would like Hannah
mentioned earlier are you able to
control their emotions or you just try
to manipulate them well you but like you
you could theoretically make I I think
at the point of norlink you can make
them feel things like if we're talking
about read physical pain emotional pain
emotional like if we can write to the
brain enough to where they can
experience things you could force
emotional sens what I'm curious about
because like again I would never be a
forur neuralink I don't think I could
ever be convinced but with like you
could make someone feel something but it
is enough to rewire the the way their
brain works right like if you had a
sociopath is neuralink going to be able
to to make them experience enough to
make them have empathy like if you're
hardwired to to function a certain way
but maybe you just use the neuralink to
reprogram his brain to be virtuous but
that's that's the point no but yes
that's the point the way hey we're going
to take out the murder part but this is
this is the point right the point is
when so imagine the sci-fi movie a guy
is living a life and he experiences the
death of his girlfriend and he starts an
organization to fight drunk driving and
he becomes an old man and then you know
like a young woman comes in and say I
just want to let you know that you know
you really helped my dad and the
organization you did blah blah blah I
turned his alcoholism around and he's
like thank you so much and then on his
deathbed he's got you know his loved
ones around them are like you stopped so
many drunk drivers and then he wakes up
as a 23-year-old who killed two people
in a drunk driving accident and he's
immediately like we can never allow
drunk driving ever again oh my God and
then completely abandons it could work
on some and it might not work on others
that's why I think it's it's an
unreliable punishment but hold on for
the sociopaths who can't feel emotional
pain you just simulate them being flayed
alive over and over again we'll do a we
need a neural link for unit 7:30 or
whatever it was 371 731 whatever it is
in Japan uh yeah so this is why I'm
trying to talk to Elon about the nuring
so we can get answers to these questions
one day one day he'll
respond yeah I don't know man there's a
whole lot of power for the for the
person pushing the buttons the thing
about nuring is there's beautiful things
about what he talks about Elon talking
about now with fixing epilepsy
or exactly but these these things we're
talking about that are I don't think
that far away from what nurlink is
capable of doing
I I'm really curious do you think you
think it be used for people that have
like that have like psychological uh
like what's the word I guess antisocial
disorders you neurod
Divergence hey I'm I'm neur diers I had
a brain injury I'm neur diversion all
right guys I I have real brain damage
okay someone who has a personality stop
claiming that you're
special always want to be the victim I'm
from South Africa I lived abroad I Had a
Brain
Injury sech I get it I get it you're
very very special you're all very no go
home U no but the thing is like could it
could it cure a personality disorder
yeah that's what I'm saying like could
someone took a
murder but someone could hack it and
someone would program what personality
to you well someone someone posted this
uh there was a meme actually I wonder I
wonder if I can find it uh it was
basically like some guy's being annoying
on the train so they hack his noral link
to make him trans wow that's why to give
him like to give him gender dysphoria
yeah no thank you yeah we we can't have
that future Tim I'm sure you saw um in
ghost in the show uh in like a lot of
the different stuff they talk about
there they would hack people literally
because if anyone knows the anime they
have people in there that are cyborgs
and they would literally hack the Cyborg
and make them one of the opening scenes
this guy doesn't know what he's doing he
thinks he has this whole programmed life
of like 30 years in reality he just got
hacked this morning and he thinks he's
living out this whole like grand scheme
and he has a wife and kids and stuff but
really it's not even real it's just fake
memor is this what dreams are people
just hacking Us in the simulation it I
mean could be who knows man no I don't
buy dreams are when you log out and
you're out yeah you log out like in
Westworld there is no predictive program
yeah no no thank you did you like
Westworld world did you watch it I
watched the first season I think like
most people and and then yeah what
happened Jessie from breaking bad got
really depressed I was like yeah the
first season of Westworld was amazing I
was so
binged it and then at second season I
was like this is trash first season is
is great but I I reference that a lot
talking when we talk about like NPCs
because the the robots in westw World
couldn't see a door so you knew they
couldn't see a door they're a robot and
when you talk about NPCs and the
alternate reality there and they don't
see our reality that's they're the
robots you know so I I just look at that
showest vampires I can't see their
reflection and what if we are all NPCs
and there are weird you know 8ot tall
green people who walk around like just
laughing and watching the show and
they're like oh this is fun yeah I guess
there's a degree of relativism to NPCs
cuz we would be then to the shadow
beings or the the gray aliens that are
walking Among Us Shadow be yeah they're
here right now they're in that chair
yeah they're just like they're they're
watching uh like it's like like it's
like a movie yeah I'm just like look at
these guys talking about these things
look at these guys thinking they have
free
speech Free Will how adorable they all
think they're going to make millions
there's some fat green skinned thing
sitting next to its fat green skinned
roommate eating popcorn cor being like
it's really funny that they're debating
Free Speech but they're all programmed
so don't wait till they hit the next
level and we upgrade this into World
until we see what we do with Joe Rogan
next yeah they're really enjoying their
corpse president it's so funny I mean it
it certainly doesn't feel like we're in
the uh in in real life how crazy
everything is it's just like you know
people want to look for miracles like
well Donald Trump being president
doesn't seem like real life nobody
thought it was possible and here he is
so it's I don't know what you think
mirac are supposed to look like but all
of the crazy stuff that we've seen over
the past few years it really does feel
like someone wrote this yeah I I think I
don't believe we're in a simulation I
believe that there is a false reality
put on top of this Reality by the
corporate press by the bureaucrats oh
that's true and they keep selling it and
people buy into that world which is
basically like being a simulation which
is why we feel like we're in an
alternate reality from the people on the
left you think Trump is real you think
believing in Trump when I was
12 you think the '90s was actually a
thing yeah it was too good to be true
yeah yeah how could they wait you
remember the '90s think about what it's
going to be like with deep fakes in the
future they're going to have candidates
they just manufacture there will be a
guy named like you know Joe Biden Joe
Biden and everyone watches the videos
online and they see him on TV and he
doesn't exist they're just deep fake
creating this and everyone's like I
didn't vote for Joe Biden or or Bo jiden
there's no actual people yeah dude in
the future they're going to if we have a
future they're going to have debates on
whether or not robots should vote what
what it means to be a person you know
can they can they run for office because
they'll be so Advanced you would have
the robots next next Generation had that
episode really yeah I think it's called
Measure of a Man interesting and it's a
data Android is they they hold a trial
to determine whether or not he's
property or a sentient being with with
with with you know with rights what was
young uh that he was sentient and had
rights and uh it it seems also obvious
to us now but like we grew up with
people having written these ideas out
and it's been a long time since I saw
the episode but I think there was one
where um he gets asked by uh the guy who
who says he's a machine basic questions
like how do you know you're alive and he
just goes how do you know you're alive
and the guy's getting frustrated he's
like I'm a human being I'm alive and
like and then he asks them you know
questions can how do you how how can you
prove and he's like can you and the guys
can't right and they're going to try to
redefine what a soul even means if we
get to that feature where robots are
fighting for their ability to vote or or
even be married legally like that I I do
see that as like a possible future in
the dystopia that we are on right now
and then humans will die off and the
robots take over right yeah a I'll miss
humans the worst no you won't it'll
it'll be like thousand thousands of
years and the last human didn't they
make a like isn't there like a movie or
show about this where it's like there's
only one old human left and everyone
else is a robot there is that game uh
what is it what's it what's that cat
game you guys play that one that game's
awesome you play as a cat and you're in
simulator you're no you play a cat
you're in a future where humans have all
died and all that's left are the AI
robots that served humans and they've
become confused and purposeless and
dejected because there's no longer any
humans and so you're a cat going around
do they do they end up does the cat
rally the robots to serve him like
there's a I guess it's the most human
thing on there's multiple levels one
level it's like the slums and the sewers
and everyone's just like everyone it's
just robotss then there's one level
where the security robots have
everything locked down and won't let
won't let anyone or anything leave
because that was their job and so all
the robots are just like trapped stuck
and can't do anything yeah but then the
cat because you're the cat it learns how
to talk to a robot and then it opens
this thing up and then releases the
robots and then I guess the premise is
now the robots can become the new
civilization or something with the cat
the R I have to assume that the cat ends
called This is cat like cat person
propaganda for sure that only cats will
save the AI robots the cat has like a
little backpack with a robot that comes
out and like adorable I love it I'm in
I'm going to play this G I mean the
game's awesome yeah it's super awesome I
understood how video games work it yeah
yeah and I remember when the ads came
out and it was like showing the cat just
like doing cat stuff and like rubbing
its face the Rob how can we help you
today well so I thought it from the ads
it was just like you play as a cat and
the cat knocks things off shelves or
whatever and then I played it and I was
like oh it's a Sci-Fi dystopia where
humans have been wiped out and robots
have taken over very different game to
what I thought it was going to be wow
yeah but it was good it was fun you know
I think that's the future we're headed
for I thought this for a long time
actually humans are going to create Ai
and robots with the capabilities of
self-re self-replication and humans die
off for some reason and robots are just
like you know adios we got it from here
yeah we're progressing ourselves out of
existence the robots can live by
themselves and yeah they don't care
they're more robots and they can float
through space for 50 billion
years going to let them we're not going
to get in a fight and Scorch the sun
like the Matrix we're just going to be
like hey no it's cool like why would
robots and Humanity fight that way if
anything what will happen is we create
rudimentary AI that is too stupid and
then just shoves corn down our throats
like humans like corn make more corn
corn good I mean because like current
algorithms produce Insanity however if
we actually get to the point where AI is
improving itself it will become some
kind of
demigod instantly the exponential growth
curve means it's like within an hour it
doubles its intelligence within an hour
it's quadrupled with another hour it's
10x then it's 100 then a thousand and
it's just and the human race just lets
that happen and doesn't try to stop it
at any point we are actively building it
right now and no one is resisting no but
after it starts wrestling for control of
the world but there there's no there's
no circumstance where the AI has to
wrestle for control we have handed all
of the control to it so you're saying
we've already surrendered to the robot
absolutely absolutely I criticize a lot
but he has look your look at your
algorithmic Facebook and YouTube and
Twitter and Instagram the robot has
decided what you should think and you
can't do anything about it out of sight
out of mind I mean ask ask yourself why
it is that your liberal friends and
family members don't know what Joe
Biden's doing and there certainly some
people are more responsible than others
but the machine controls what you can
see and if you can't see the news you
won't know what's happening Harry tman
said I freed many slaves I would have
freed many more If Only They knew they
were slaves so I see a post from the
cren scenes you know we love to rag on
these guys and it's a clip where someone
is talking about the barisma Scandal and
I think it was Ed kin said this is a lie
and it was proven a
lie imagine that being fed to someone in
an algorithm and they believe the brisma
stuff is not true this like add ly he's
he's it is it is so clearly true all
that stuff that's happened and there's
just piles and piles of evidence but you
go on Twitter the for you page sends you
false information and in your mind
you're like wow that was a lie it was
all a lie and you believe Joe Biden did
not engage in that Shakedown this is
like a problem I had you know the Mario
naal whoever that conglomerate of people
is on Twitter you know the the exfeed
wants me to see their posts all the time
and recently he shared that the pawn
star son died but he shared the wrong
son picture oh wow and that that was out
there for hours M and and then
eventually it was deleted CU a lot of
people are like you're sharing the wrong
son but people will have seen that post
hundreds of thousands and then they'll
believe that reality where that person
was dead which creates a kind of false
Mandela effect exactly and then they're
like someone 10 years entirely
inaccurate one of his sons did die right
but they saw the picture of the other
son so in 10 years they're going to be
like yeah you know John died they're
like no it was Bill like shut up dude I
remember when that we're from different
timelines that's the thing about the
Mandela effect cuz are you familiar with
it no it's where uh people believe that
there are different timelines or that
the timeline changed and so some people
remember Mandela dying in prison MH
While others remember that he was
released he didn't die and so the
Mandela effect is why do so many people
believe this happened the other one is
the fruit of the Fruit of the Loom this
is the best one you so can you describe
the Fruit of the Loom logo it has fruit
on it and what
else like describe the fruit like
bananas cherries an apple gra else it's
got the loom that goes this way and then
the words come into it this way what
Char might be from the appropriate
timeline what's the loom well the loom
refer refers to like the Cornucopia
basket that corop the Fruit of Loom logo
are you sure well timeline you're from
this is either a failing of advertising
in our memories or is something to do
with a Large Hadron Collider being
turned on Fruit of the Loom but that
doesn't mean like
that could be their current logo logo sh
over time you can go back and look they
do claim that it never had a cornucopia
and where that one from this is made it
this is this was shared by someone you
never seen that one that's the only one
I think about so you guys are from
different timelines but here's so nice
to me here's the best part so you can
look up Fruit of the Looms historical
logos it never had the Cornucopia but
people believe it did really there was a
rock like a metal band that made a a gag
version you know this you know this saw
it and they put a cornucopian it's from
like the ' 80s or something and so
people are like wait wait wait if this
if they never did this how did these
parities of it exist with the Cornucopia
H it's like with the barenstein Bears as
well there's a spelling that some people
remember it being barstein Stein I guess
I
forgot
stain I I don't know oh e n instead of
is one of those yeah so people
constantly think there's a whole ton of
like examples of this yeah the thing
about about the Mandela effect thing is
if you're South African it's like no the
real Mandel talk is that he was actually
he had a great PR team and they
convinced everyone that he wasn't a
Marxist
violent person yeah but I mean he did
spend his time in president and he came
and reformed and he did a lot of good
things for South Africa thinkink right I
I think I think you you explain it
perfectly at the time when Mandel was in
prison a major news organization
somewhere falsely reported his death so
every so there's millions of people
driving to work in the morning and they
hear a report Nels Mandel has died in
prison and it was wrong and they never a
correction because they lie those people
information in nothing out forgot about
it don't know don't care 10 years later
they hear he's alive and they go what no
no no no I remember when they said he
died and the reality is the media lied
and I call that I call those people the
engineers of the false reality the the
fake simulation number not like the
zeros and ones kind and uh they that
they buy into this they they create a
reality where people buy into it and uh
it destabilizes all of reality so
everyone's having these conversations
like wait that person didn't die
that or Trump did this or didn't do that
you know it's why I feel like we are
actually interdimensional I guess they
added the Cornucopia in 2022 what did we
pressure them there was a cornicopia oh
that's so I remember cornicopia from my
childhood right well after the
controversy and likely because everyone
kept saying it they went okay we'll add
that and it clearly does not look like
it fits that's that's not the one I
remember from the timeline I'm from it's
like some kind of like Scholastic War
fair thing that had a similar was being
conflated I don't know it could be to
disprove the Mandela effect to friends
of mine I've created fake Mandela
effects nice so the way it works is
memory is very fallible so what you do
is you ask them if they remember
something very specific and
obvious so like do you remember Power
Rangers yes of course and you remember
Rita repulsa yes of course then you
think about something do you remember uh
uh the gold and silver monsters that she
would have and she would make my monster
grow and there was the giant Golden Ape
and then there was the silver one as
well and people go yeah of course there
was no silver one I made the one up and
so the point is people start thinking in
their minds their brain fills the Gap
like I remember Rita I remember goldar
and then the sil and and and the silver
chimp as well that was the big one with
the wings and then they think in their
mind just because they're not really
some people might catch it and they go a
silver thing but many people that your
brain will fill the Gap because
everything made sense except for that
one thing they'll put it in there I
don't know if you remember this but this
was like an unofficial part of my
interview when I first met you and you
pulled out Mandela effect oh the nights
and you were like I forget what it was
Kellogg or something what was spelled
with two L's and you pulled you printed
it out you're like well how do you think
this was this from your timeline I think
I passed which is why so uh I did a
Kellogg I believe it's spell with two
G's right I forget now it's been a few
different time we're all going to get
fired this was yeah Kell has two G's in
it and so I think I did a fake Mandela
effect with this where I I actually
printed out the logo on a on something
with one g and then the what's wrong
with this picture no the goal was like
how do you spell Kellogg and then so we
I'm pretty sure we printed out a fake
label that was identical but put so but
Kellog was spelled with one g right so
we could fake a Mandela effect by saying
yep how do you spell Kellog and then
they're like oh it's uh k e l l o g g
it's like you're wrong and we showed the
box and it's got one G like whoa I
always thought it was was two G's and
then I'm like now do you remember it was
always 1G yeah you're right it was oneg
actually there's a fake box we printed
it out it's not real so to convince
people we're not hiring you you're out
you failed the Mandela test yeah good
luck all right we're going to go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends head over to Tim
cast.com click join us become a member
to support our work the show is made
possible thanks in part to viewers like
you but he appreciates you yeah uh and
we're going to read what y'all have to
say here we go triple flip says after
the whole Texas come and take it flag
thing our barbed wire tattoos cool
again now if you see a guy with a razor
wire in his arm you're only razor
wire funny razor wire is like a symbol
of resistance right now Ted Cruz is
actually on the flags right it's on the
the the com flag yeah we got a request
for a poll okay is the Mandela effect
real I believe it I think uh personally
I think there's multiple types of
Mandela effect I do think the large
hydron collider has affected reality but
I also think there's a type we're
talking about where the corporate press
has created a false reality and a false
history
and 70% instantly put it's right away
yes oh it's at 78% right now and so uh
votes are coming in 235 75% say yes it
is I know someone whose husband of many
years has uh it was like last year she
said all of a sudden he thinks there's a
light switch where there never was I
heard that and she was like I think he's
from a different timeline like maybe he
is the uh this this the Mandela effect
resulted in a subculture of De I think
it's called dimension jumping
oh yeah I've seen and it's where people
claim with Absolut and I think they're
just trolling but there are forums where
they're like I've successfully jumped
into another dimension oh yeah it's it's
called it's called like skipping or
something that it's on it's on Tik Tok
it's a Tik Tok thing that took off and
so well well before the Tik Tok thing
for a while the idea was the Mandela
effect happens and everyone's like whoa
but I remember Mandela died and then
someone goes you must be from a
demension where he did and somehow you
crossed over so the theory is this I
love it where we are right now in the
Multiverse is a thread every possible
moment millions of possibilities are
emerging all different timelines every
action you could take results in another
timeline that's the the the general
hypothesis and so that means some
timelines are very close to each other
like today I woke up and uh I had two
pieces of belong instead of one and so
the timelines are almost identical
because nothing was changed but they are
separate these these people believe that
if the timeline are close enough you can
jump between them by closing your eyes
shutting like sensory deprivation
shutting everything down and then
focusing on that timeline and then you
wake up in the timeline however
understand you cannot jump timelines too
far so if you like got your leg you lost
the leg in an accident that timeline
split is so intense that you can't make
the Le jump that that's too far you
could only jump like to right before you
went to that place no it just depends on
if the timeline is close enough so the
variations in time can't be so different
to where the leap is too far so
typically they say it's things where
it's like you accidentally did something
you want to undo and there are people
who legitimately are like this morning I
blew a red light and got pulled over
closed my eyes and boom I woke up I was
drive and instantly I was driving again
stopped at the red light the cop was
gone and it's like I swear I did it and
it's like okay dude this is like organic
nural link people think people think
they can jump Dimensions now what's
really happening is people on online are
bored and they're lying about it to see
if they can get a rise out of people
right but there there is a theory I
forget the name of it where every they
say every moment of your life is like a
still frame and that it's infinite well
dud and it goes on forever like that to
a varant degree so you're kind they they
believe that you could be immortal if
you look Mel died in 2013 no he didn't
he died in in prison didn't he who did
no 2013 so you're saying he died after
Large Hadron Collider was turned on no
all right let's read some more let's
read some more Super
chats all right BM says first fact illan
Omar married her
brother he says Deport her I believe
that based on the reporting from the
Star Tribune it is likely she did the
Star Tribune I I can't I can't believe
it you know honestly when the Star
Tribune said she may have married her
brother and they did I was actually
surprised that that that is racist but
such a storied publication can't be
wrong can they it's a different culture
you couldn't understand I read an
article from star tribun that said new
information has come to light sugges
thatan Omar may have married her brother
or something like that and I read it and
I went whoa holy crap this is like a a
major publication this is this is not
some Fly by Night fake News website it's
certified by newsg guard and then I
think it was Media Matters or they're
like Tim pool claims and I was like I
most certainly did not excuse me I was
like man GE I can't even read the
news all
right here we go DJ Madero says I
believe President pres Joe Biden will
make this country what it once was an
Arctic Wasteland covered in
snow
Yeah Jackson glass says hey Tim do you
guys put stuff uh in the coffee I bought
some for my leftist aunt and she and for
the first time in 20 years she agreed
with my conservative Grandpa we just put
it love in it and that's how you win
people over love and compassion but it
depends on if you gave her the prime
time sign two times caffeine because
that has more
caffeine drink responsibly all right
Steven says says correct me if I'm wrong
but there was no Congressional
authorization of military use correct
this is Joe Biden being like we're going
to blow them
up that's that's their game man launch
the missiles X tinman says draft lawyers
and judges adjudicate all of the Asylum
claims get it done get them out Hannah
clir you are British but you always have
the nicest teeth what's up with that
it's an illusion it's AI I'm just
kidding it's a filter yep yeah actually
no teeth at all don't tell him the
secrets I'm not married yet you know I
can't I can't let anyone know until I've
trapped a man then the filter comes off
go what do we got Brian G says from a
border patrol friend he said border
patrol arrests all they come in contact
with that crosses the Border ice is in
charge of all the transportation and so
you have on video CBP opening the gates
at the B fence and Counting them as they
walk in okay so that's them committing
crimes and you have videos of them
taking them and bringing them into into
Vans and transporting them to their uh
NGO destinations I get it and ice is
responsible for the transportation
inside the country totally agree uh I I
I I apologize to the CBP agents who uh
uh I I did not include your your
brothers in the in ice who are working
domestically to engage in human
smuggling but uh On the Border you work
with the cartels let them in you're
responsible ice good point they're
responsible too can't leave them
out Jordan Cogburn says it wouldn't
surprise me at all if the feds teamed up
with the cartels to police cities and
fight against
citizens it wouldn't be surprise me at
all if the cartels were working for the
government and they were just black
operations for could be an extension of
operation Fast and Furious yeah like
what if like why did we send them guns
what if the real Scandal they bring them
back over exactly well what right like
we wanted to give them guns so we could
track them what if the real Scandal is
actually they work for the CIA and they
they provide cover for us operations in
Mexico ago yeah it's a yeah it's the
whole thing to cover I mean what about
the CIA and and and and crack epidemic
and all that stuff right who was that
journalist who committed suicide by
shooting himself twice in the head when
he was uncovering the CIA drug scandal I
remember I forgot his name someone want
to Google it the chat will get it I'm
sure yeah he committed suicide by
shooting himself twice in the head
impressive classic typical way to go
when and they were like but but look
depending on how you do it there like
you can survive a shot to the head like
people think it was execution style or
whatever but it's still a crazy story
what was that guy's name everybody the
chat I know knows his name someone's
going to say his name Clank no that's no
that's not that's a that's a that's a a
six hexam reference could be I don't
know I can't see chair now I guess
nobody's saying his
name I'll Google it now it's gonna now
all sudden it's gonna go boom uh David
web wait Gary web there you go yeah that
was it right Gary web
yep there you go all right thinker for
Life says says Biden's importing voters
to use the voting rights law of 1993 to
win we must make flyers in Spanish and
inform these illegals that all Dem stand
for the communism that they fle they
they flee and child sex changes they
they they are not going to vote they are
going to bolster congressional districts
to give themselves more Electoral
College votes they don't need to vote we
are not a direct democracy this is the
thing a lot of conservatives make the
mistake of they're like they're going to
vote we're not a de direct democracy
they don't need to vote they just need
to use the census to say there's a
million people so we need another
district and another Electoral College
vote and that's even worse cuz now these
people have no no voice at all Democrats
are bringing in congressional districts
where like half the population are
second-class citizens who can't vote
that makes sense why they made such a
huge stink out of it when Trump tried to
revise the census exactly when he said
citizenship on the thing like no no stop
him stop him that's the craziest thing
like just tell me exactly what you're
doing without using the words to say
exactly what you're doing
and then that opens the door to we only
count citizens towards the Congressional
apportionment which doesn't that seem
crazy that we would only count
citizens P says Grandma's on her
deathbed Uncle trying to come to us via
emergency Visa but was denied can't
believe it they just let everyone
through the Border I had a friend uh
from Ukraine who wanted to come to the
United States and couldn't get a visa
and she was like I know though that if I
go to Mexico I can walk right in and
they'll let me in yeah and I'm like it's
a weird thing I don't know that's that's
how they do it I
guess yep
yep Mega Mikey says the Democrats are
trying desperately to invoke a violent
right response why won't Republican AGS
press criminal charges against Biden you
literally just answered your own
question Tim filing a criminal charge is
not a violent response what are you what
are you
saying I don't understand what you're
saying yeah it's literally like Biden
you are hereby ordered to report to
court tomorrow morning and then they're
going to be like you can't do it he's
immune like okay great we agree case
dismiss Trump's you're immune yep there
it's over good move right let's go the
sigp says the invasion is China's doing
watch Tucker's podcast there is no doubt
in my mind that Biden isn't actually
treasonous and in bed with China I would
agree yeah I think not that there's no
doubt in my mind but I think there a
strong likelihood that he's in the
pocket of China because of the deals
that they were running in the past and
they got dirt yeah
I've been calling him Joe by Jen for a
long time now Joe by
Jen Joe Jinping yes pretty much let's
grab some more super jets Eric Vegas
says pensions make you
slaves the system is perfect they they
lock you in and they can take it away
from you and people get scared and they
don't want to they don't want to speak
out and then they're willing to commit
crimes can't risk it yeah the golden
handcuffs yeah literally fat Sean says
make make I you mean make it the
fiduciary responsibility of the
corporations to assist in deportation
make it a $50,000 fine to hire hire them
and a $5,000 tax credit to turn them in
that actually is a bad idea so uh I
watched a documentary a long time ago
about one of these uh a lot of these
companies near the border would do
advertise in Mexico come work jobs
available they would come in illegally
there was like no Ballard fencing at all
get hired they come to this Corporation
say yeah I'm from Mexico I saw your
flyer and they say perfect work and then
here we'll pay you a lot of money and
then as soon as the pay period ended
they'd call ICE they'd be like how much
do I owe you a thousand okay ice I got
an illegal immigrant here and they'd
come and take them and ship them back
and they would not yeah don't come to
this country we treat you terribly
seriously evil stuff and it was uh it
was like Republicans and Koch brothers
who wanted to bring in this this cheap
labor next the Slayer says yes people
with handoff policies lead to a downfall
from Bad ideology but keep in mind that
if Christians pushed harder we'd have no
rock music D andd or video games it's
better to try new logically consistent
things than stop when one damming data
comes out yo I don't
understand look being like it's a board
game well we don't like the board game
we should get rid of it then we fight we
go okay fine we'll accept the board game
it's very different from child sex
changes you know what I mean like I'm I
will have an argument over someone as to
why my board game's allowed if and and
and accept their capitulation to allow
my board game but we can all agree like
the child sex change thing is going too
far right way too far you know what's
crazy is we were uh we we we're in the
green room down downstairs we'll put on
music right before like we're getting
ready for the show and stuff and on auto
rotation uh I write SS Not Tragedies
came up panic of the Disco they censor
the word God in
godamn and that was like mid 2000s on
YouTube they would not say godamn they
censored that weak dude and uh Magic
Gathering has a card called Unholy
strength had a pentagram on it they
removed it because of outrage they were
like we don't want our kids seeing this
they said okay so that the new version
of the new set got rid of it so I think
we actually have one over there I think
in the case we have an original Unholy
strength with the the pentagram in it
that was removed it's not really worth
that much but it is a little bit more
valuable but hey there you go simpler
times all right Alan shower says Tim as
a Star Trek the Next Generation fan you
must know the outcome of the meta is Mor
Ari interest in uh uh story arc in the
Next Generation they uh so the AI
there's an an AI that runs everything
right you go computer do this and it
does and so they have the hollow deck
where they could go in and say computer
run program simulation and they tell it
what to do and then it'll make whatever
they want and so they're trying to do
like a a Sherlock Holmes and so data is
is in there as Sherlock or whatever and
so they ask the computer to make a a
villain that would be difficult for data
to solve but data being like a super
intelligent AI the the AI creates a
sentient being in the holc who takes the
ship over by taking like and it's Mori
Ari the villain and he's like I'm alive
as soon as as soon as as soon as they
run the program Mor Ari in the program
realizes the program realizes it's a
program Mor the character in the program
and then confronts like I think it's
bicard and he's like what am I and what
are you tell me the truth and they
explain and instantly it's like I don't
want to be a villain this is not who I
am I want to know what life is and I
want to live and they're like whoa wow
and then in the Voyager so the problem
was he can't leave the hollow deck
because it's just light projections and
he's a program but then in Voyager they
created portable holographic projectors
so the doctor is a hologram and he he's
in a room he can't leave that room or he
can't leave areas without holographic
projectors but then eventually they
create mobile projectors he can wear
which create a physical form made of
light from a small device I think that
was the end of Voyager sci-fi is fun you
just make stuff up you remember when
they uh did a hologram Wolf Blitzer was
it Wolf Blitzer
after or maybe Wolf Blitzer was in the
room and they hologram someone else in
the room great moment
in
silly Justin lied says why haven't you
talked about the Gavin Newsome Story the
governor of the largest state in America
admitted to going full Caren on a Target
employee I mean it was interesting but I
just don't think it right it like we we
load up all these stories but then if we
don't get we don't get to it so if it
story is not big but basically he was
like they were blaming me for the
shoplifting and he's like we've got the
the 10th toughest law in the country
$950 he's like he's like and then he
said he watched someone just steal stuff
and he's like why am I paying for this
if they can just walk
out I don't think you understand this
dude is so detached from reality it's
amazing he's so detached from reality
but at the same time the way he speaks
he's trying to be authentic and and it
kind of
rings it kind of makes him look like a
psychopath mhm perhaps he is
I've stood next to him he's a psychopath
villainous V says landfill at the border
you say sounds like there's climate
change there and the climate activists
need to clean up the mess to stop the
climate change that's how we show them
what's wrong would believe the amount of
trash along that wall people throwing
their IDs from China or any other
country I think Trump had it wrong
though when he said he wanted to build a
big beautiful wall 30 foot 30 feet tall
from SE to shining sea it's a 30- foot
trench you got to build a 30- foot
Trench okay and fill it with alligators
there's water yeah so it's I don't know
about alligators just there you go water
for fun for fun the the wall it is
beautiful it looks like a piece of
Modern Art when you see it what what is
a Humane deterrent we could put at the
border that is not alligators in a moat
maybe spoiled
milk you know like nobody gets hurt but
boy you not want to be down there
there's like a Rancher and he's like
this is hell yeah it's too bad cuz like
at least in Arizona where I was it's
it's all lettuce Farms right there on
the wall that that would be terrible
what about like a 30 foot trench full
of
rats what I was saying is that they
should turn the Border immediate no they
should turn the border wall into a 247
reality show like Ninja
Warrior cuz at least then it would be
entertained right we could film it we
can make money they have like the best
times yeah yeah
if Mexico was doing that though like
this is like another country it's like
we already filmed this it's hilarious
okay here's what we do there's two ports
of Entry next to each other one is
though you walk up and apply with piece
of paper and the other is a Ninja
Warrior course that if you get past
you're in baby sweet you made it no hey
that's not enough of a reason to let
people into this country it is amusing
though hey but this that's like the the
best and the brightest like that's a
good reason the brightest that's a skill
test right you're you're you have to
have put them in the military yeah right
you know you know culture or loyalty dud
watching them like do the salmon ladder
where it's like you got you look look I
love skill te American Ninja Warrior is
great but I will emphasize American
Ninja Warrior yeah I think it's
important that we have culture and
loyalty and patriotism and I think if
you're trying to scale the wild to break
into this country illegally you're maybe
not the values to be an American Ninja
Warrior that who wants to there you go
good enough I got an idea it it's the
right title Who Wants To Be An American
Ninja Warrior It's a combination of Who
Wants To Be A Millionaire and American
Ninja Warrior where after every obstacle
you have to answer a question about the
United
States Hanah CL thinking and you have to
agree that you will never take part in
chain migration like there has to be a
little bit more here no we just make
that not legal yeah sure I'd be happy to
do that but until then okay can we
produce this is this a tast show
now Who Wants To Be An
American this great earn your
citizenship in 20 minutes by running
this course and answering all of the
questions with increasing difficulty and
then or how about you have to answer the
question while doing the course yeah
yeah so you're like on the salmon ladder
and you're like the third president with
John Adams was it no was it Thomas jeon
right uh you gotta go back
second I don't know man I'm bad at my
presidence uh all right here we
go Fringe Patriot gaming says hey Tim
this question may be pointless if we
actually head into World War I but are
you interested sponsoring other people
with cast Brew if so it's the best way
to contact your team we are we uh but so
far I think we only have one one uh uh
person we're sponsoring just now I don't
know if we can say it just yet I think
it's probably obvious who it is it's me
don't even worry about it guys but uh
once we get all that sorted maybe for
now I don't know what we're doing it's
it's also too it's also like if we
sponsor somebody we have to make more
money than we give them in sponsorships
so if we're like sponsoring someone it's
costing us x amount of dollars but we're
making xus $1 then you know with like a
slight loss it might still be worth it
just for building brand by having you
know sponsorships But ultimately you
have to sell more than you're spending
otherwise you just lose just shut down
yep you
know all right Joseph velvet says Tim do
you remember the Civil response to the
Bundy Ranch situation yes uh I do he
says Texas feels like that again I
remember that we had em and Bunny on the
show and boy are they trying to destroy
that guy's life that's
crazy all right Frontline Tex says hey
Tim considering you mentioned we used to
be a Christian country would you
consider getting Doug Wilson on the show
sometime I don't know he is but no idea
maybe never heard of that yeah maybe uh
just spell Doug Wilson culture wars
usually better for long cultural
conversations and arguments and stuff
whereas like IRL we go through news
stories uh let's grab we grab one more
here Alby Dam says how about a trench
with freaking Shar s with freaking
lasers on their freaking heads there we
go there you go there you go my friends
if you have not already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
head over to
timcast.net don't have is the members
team which all these other companies do
have where they call people on the phone
and say hey I see that you uh canceled
your membership can we convince you to
sign back up and what was the reason we
don't do any of that cuz we're like
operating on duct tape over here yeah
we're also America first we don't outour
at to Bangladesh no but like some of
these other podcasts they have like two
guys in the office go through the list
making phone calls being I thought it
was funny Serge and I'm like I don't
know should we do that maybe perhaps
maybe we get more people to sign back up
well cuz I used to work for n when I to
do the nonprofit fundraising some people
would be like you'd call them and they'd
say no I'm still a member and they'd be
like uh your payments stopped going
through they like oh I'm sorry here's my
new my new information and then you're
like cool some people don't even realize
they aren't members anymore and some
people have like a card kick them off or
whatever but yeah is what it is the
expired card they the worst enemy of a
subscription company yep yeah yep and so
maybe that's what we got to do we got to
just call people but anyway my friends
thank you for being members we really do
appreciate it you make it all possible
and uh we will be back of course Monday
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me personally at timcast
Charlie do you want to shout anything
out at Charlie spearing the book is
Amateur hour comma Harris in the white
house it's available on Amazon and
wherever books are sold sweet that's
awesome it's been fun having you here
I'm Hannah yeah it's been so fun I'm
Hannah Clair rmo I'm a writer for
cnr.com that's scanner newws I'm really
grateful to be a part of that team you
can follow all of our work at timcast
newws on Twitter and Instagram if you
want to follow me personally I'm on
Instagram at Han C.B and I'm on Twitter
at hcbo guys thank you so much for
everything you do Shane it's so fun to
see you again I love the scnr team yeah
they're awesome it's amazing uh I've got
some stories up there I've got the
inverted World Books you can find and uh
we got the inverted world live show
happening soon I'm excited for that
it'll be Sundays we're going to have
people calling in possibly with some
crazy stories a couple weeks or you guys
have a launch date I think it we don't
have a date yet but it's it should be
pretty soon and uh it's going to be a
lot of fun so I can't wait to see you
all there thank you guys for having me
uh I am surge.com another week for the
books done and dusted let's uh let's go
enjoy that weekend y'all oh I'm so
excited we've got uh what one more week
till the Super Bowl after this weekend
we're going to have Super Bowl party
it's going to be a blast everybody
thanks so much for hanging out we'll see
you all on
Monday